You
These balls across your face
Why are you eating? I don't know
Oh my god, where's the game sound? Oh, yeah, look at me. That's a chancer right there
She's
Okay, I'll put us all at the bottom
I
Always get a snap from uh one of my friends her name's bubby. Oh, and uh, yeah
She I always I only got snapchat just for her because I never use it
So I was just like she was like, yeah snapchat. I'm like, no
I
Here and if anyone else asks me no
Never
Man man put it on speakers and let the neighbors hear you want people to hear damn
Oh my
Get a little frisky. Damn
We had headshots. No, I only see
Ah
Backshots what
People still use snap. I but yeah, I guess they do I didn't know
Let me move this girls down
All right, let me know when you guys are ready to start I'm ready. Yeah, I'm my fingers itching on the play button
Did you just purr? Yeah
Yeah
I mean I can purr for you. Oh, can you make that kitty purr for me, baby girl?
Hello sunrise, how was your day? I mean, I'm hanging out with three hot ladies next to me. So I'm doing pretty nice
Yeah
All right
I'm on the end
I'm on the edge
of glory
I thought I had a controller, but it doesn't seem to work. So
Oh, yeah, I don't know if controllers are how do you how do you drag people?
Oh dear pulling a zero with me. Oh e pull his e
All right, let's go. Come on appala
Come on my pets
Oh dear, oh my goodness, maybe we should have re-evaluated the order that we're standing in it's fine
It's fine
Thank you for saying bless you guys. I much appreciate. Thank you
I'm sure if you're capable though, why is this guy sound so familiar?
He does sound hot. Yeah, I was thinking he sounds like the guy from sucker punch
The old man that tells you wise things. I just watched that movie the other day. It sounds like him
I love sucker punch. That's like my all-time top 10 movies to watch every now and then same
It's like one of us like it's mid, but it's great. Yeah
I just like the really intense fight scenes when they switch over and I'm just like yeah
I did it for our members watch along everybody liked it. So I'm glad nice
All right, which way we going we have to communicate what is happening
All right, so we're just gonna go we're just we're just going go. All right
Oh, okay
All right
Yeah, yeah, we got this game
I was watching markiplier play this game with his friends
And they were literally called it just going no stopping. Thank you. Thank you. I was getting the strat
Oh, okay, I guess I'll come too. I'm also terrible at platforming. So this is great
I
I'm sorry. I did it on purpose
There you go. There you go. All right. I'm bringing up the rear
Oh gosh, I don't want to follow
You can only pull up the person in front of you and behind you so
You can you guys in the middle can pull either way
I
We're doing pretty good so far. Yeah, I think we're almost there
Oh my god, this will do they know
Little is never little. Oh my god. You guys almost pulled me off. All right. All right. We're good. We're good. Okay
Just walk straight just edge edge a little bit. Yeah. Yeah
Just
Nice. All right proceed
Apollo you are a queen to make our gameplay worse. Don't go forward. There's a hole there
We are one oiled one well oiled machine. We're literally just telepathically communicating right now
Yeah, we're so in sync with everyone
It's like our it's like our periods are synced up. We're just like that. Uh, okay, so these will throw us across
Uh, okay, uh, all right
I
Was I'm warning them I watched
I'm the type of person that watches a lot of gameplay of something before I started a majority of the time
Now we got the we're doing fine. We're doing actually pretty good. I think
All right, go go
speed run speed run
Yeah, let's go speed run speed run
Speed run moment. All right
Okay, this part. I can't speed run. I gotta go slow. Is there a way to not fall off?
Is there like minecraft where you hold shift? No
You could dash but shift is not yeah, you can sprint
Can you guys pull me sprinting is the right move? Yeah, I'd be pulled. Oh, I'll just be pulled to my
dangling
this
I just kind of move little by little
You can just use your mouse and just trace along it to be honest with you
Yeah, I would require gamer skills, which I do not have
All right, we got this
There we got this we got this
Oh, my god. Oh, look, there's a big dude over there. See that guy
Behind the mountain. Oh, shit to your left. He's just hanging
What's that mouse do?
Hello raiders. Hi. Hey, hi. Oh, I'm like, is that the raider?
We're just girls, you know just girls being girls. Uh, okay, don't touch the laser or it will fling us
What? Wait, what happened to us?
Holy shit
I'm back. Okay. Okay. Holy shit. That was fine. That was fine. That was fine. Don't read. Oh my god. Hello. Hi raiders
Hi, siri, honey
Okay
Hello raiders
So we're gonna go one at a time jumping over. Okay. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
Don't touch it
No, we gotta all do it together I'll do it together
Ready
Everyone get in front of it a little bit get in like straight up. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
That's all right to the left count somebody count down. Okay, ready?
Okay, there we go
Okay, we've got a whole single single file. Yeah, okay, there you go
All right, and now we gotta uh climb up through that we gotta
Mario
Well, you have to hold it. No, you don't gotta hold it. Yeah, it doesn't automatically
Yeah, it's like we're playing mario world. Yeah, no worries
Nifty
Just jump
We can also we can pull you up. So oh, yeah
I hope you had a lovely stream series. Oh my god. Did you guys look up yet?
Okay, now this is a jump pad
Yep. All right, we need to we all need to position ourselves
Now there's the it's that way straight ahead
Frank I got a little closer
Okay ready three two one
It's okay, it's okay. Nice. Oh nice
Easy easy clap. Nice. Okay. Perfect. Perfect. Go through the tunnel. Okay, there we go
Oh scary tunnel
Secret tunnel
Through the mountains secret secret tunnel
Try as I haven't puked yet. That's awesome. All right
If you need to puke just look away and we'll drag you. Okay. All right, you'll be okay. Thank you
Maybe it's a good thing. I'm on the end. All right. So this takes immense skill. There's multiple paths. Some lead to dead
Stay right here. I'm holding her back. She's like a leased child
I
Forward like that. All right. I trust so appall. Yeah. Okay. No is there can lead
How do we get up jump jump and you should automatically vault and press w. All right. Is that the right way?
Oh
Oh my god, I'm just gonna sit here. I'm gonna pull you up
Y'all better not fall down. I swear to god
Oh my god
Oh wings
I'll give you an item. Yeah, grab it because if we if we get 10 we can glide easier down
What just happened? Oh the fuck reset us. We did so bad that it reset us right to the beginning
Uh, there is a cheat that'll send us to back to where we oh there we go
I was trying to figure it out. Sorry. Oh
Yeah, we're allowed to do this. Okay. Yeah
Yeah, let's that'll save us some time
All right, I'm just gonna let you guys fall me along and watch how this happens
Which is the right path this way? Oh, well, that's under
Uh
Oh
Okay, okay
Okay, right. We're good. We're good. Okay. Okay. Just um, just don't fall. Just don't fall. Good strap
Just don't fall skill issue. That's all
Let's see. Let's see
I'm I am commandeering this mission
Uh
We're almost there. Oh, yeah, we're almost there. Oh, let's see. We should go this way
Uh, uh, uh
What's going on? Don't fall. Don't fall. Oh, I'm good. I'm good. I'm good
I've got you though. If you fall, I've got you. Don't worry. We can do it trust
Yeah, all right guys good
Yeah, I'm Gucci
We're almost there
Almost we're almost there. We're almost there. Oh my god to the skull pile. You got this
Push
Okay, I can't climb. Oh frick hold on
Oh
This one's harder. I don't know why I wouldn't let me just do that. I'll fall. All right
Okay, okay. So you gotta go
There we go. There we go. We did it. Oh
Oh, we made it easy easy. Let's go
Okay, jump pad watch out just
Oh my god
Oh, okay
Okay, so this we just time it, right? Yeah. Yeah. So let's do the next one
Good job, good job
You think they're going to start making suggestive jokes probably
During the game or be too angry at each other for falling to care about anything else probably who knows
Who knows we'll see we'll see we'll see
Uh, I see some things coming up. So let's yeah, we gotta time it. We have to all do it together like in line
What's happening?
I'm trying to pull her up. Oh, I'm pulling the wrong person. Okay. All right. We gotta okay all together all together smush together
We move as one unit. Hold on pause. Okay. Okay. You can go
All right, we're good
Sorry, I got I might I might have gotten a little bit greedy there
Freya's head is going into my ass
Hey, I got two heads inside of me
Are we so vigorous to me bounce and climb this ladder?
It's just the way from being bouncy
I'm bouncing
All right
Count us off count us off. Wait, wait, wait, wait. Okay, go
Oh, go go go. It's another one. Okay. Now stop stop stop stop stop stop stop
I like we can add a little bit closer. Oh, yeah. Uh, wait, wait, wait, wait. Wait, wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
Okay, go okay, go go go go go go
We got make me sh. Yes, I think is there is the fastest out of all of us
How fast is because I'm tying your nimble?
What's in here? Is there any goodies? No, I checked last time there
All right. Let's go
side of the wings she's a suspended like a little baby okay got a time this
everybody gets to the edge we got it get to the edge get to the edge yeah yeah
okay ready ready go
I believe I can fly back up here wild
I believe I keep touch the sky okay it's a shorter it was a shorter jump alright
the crow alright we got this again easy I don't know how we landed here again but
we made it all right
short short jumps nice kind of almost have to go back you got it you got a
jump
about me being mom
damn soon she was like she be I don't think you should be on the end
We're going. We're going. Come on. Come on. Come on. This is a great swing. Okay. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. One by one. One by one. I don't think that's a good idea.
I'm trying so hard to keep us up here.
I don't know why, but whenever I clicky to eat, it pushes me forward. I'm like,
damn, no, that's not what I'm trying to do. I think it does like frame click forward as like
for the animation, it kind of pushes you forward a little bit. All right. One by one,
falling like apples. Damn. Wait, wait. You didn't say go. I'm sorry.
What? I got it. Don't worry guys. Oh my god. I'm literally going to pee myself from this.
Okay. I got you. Is there a come on, baby girl?
Let me breathe. Let me breathe. Hold on. Take a breather. Take a breather. Get the giggles out.
We look like really homeless power rangers right now.
Okay. Okay. I'm ready. I'm ready. Okay. All right. Let's not calm down and run. Just go for it.
We don't need it. We don't need it.
This is fine. Look, speed run. Speed run. Which way do we go? Okay. I think it's this way.
Lead the way, Apollo. What the hell is this? All right. Jump when now. Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no.
Oh, I see. I understand. I did not. Oh, I jumped to the ladder.
How do we? To the barrels. To what? To the barrels.
Oh my god. To the barrels. Jumps to death. All right. Okay. Go.
Okay. Sorry. Sorry.
Hell. Put them up. Put them up. Oh, shit. Hell. Come on. Come on. No. Oh, shit. Guys.
I'm going to try to swing. No, don't swing. Okay. Swing to the other side. Swing to the other side.
Go, go. Power bottles. Damn. You know you're not wrong.
All right.
Sends it. She's like, I did not give a shit. All right. Three, two, okay.
Swing me over. Somebody pull up.
Does it help if I pull on a zero when you guys are all gone? Oh, god.
All right.
I keep falling on the other side.
What if you jumped to the other side? You want us to jump? All right.
A zero. We got this. Wait. We almost got Freya. All right. We'll just jump. Yeah. Okay. Three, two, one. Go.
All right. That's fine. That's fine. We're back. We're so back.
I was so busy laughing at Freya just running off that I couldn't. I didn't walk backwards to stop
Azura from flying off and I literally. I was trying to pull. I can't. I'm literally ori losing my voice
laughing and yelling.
You know what I mean? My moms are like, my moms are like, why? Why are you like this? Oh, we are so
not back. It's already hanging. We're just climbing a ladder.
What the fuck are you doing?
All right, Freya. We'll pull you up. Just like the other of you. You're just a stripper.
On the pole. All right. Azura, are you paying attention?
I was watching Azura. Azura. Azura. Azura, did you just connect? Oh, no. Azura, please.
Oh my god.
Fatal error. Oh my god. How do you have a cracked out PC and it just keeps shooting the bed?
A player has disconnected, respawning.
Wait, if she spawns back in, is she gonna appear with us? I think so. All right.
Azura, make as much progress as we can while she's gone.
She's dragging a pole. Damn, damn. I think my game is not framed properly on OPS.
Ah, my neck. My back. All right, I'm ready. Okay, ready? Three, two, one, go. Nice. Three,
two, one, go. That was pretty fast. Oh, we're not gonna get far.
Hello, fate, mythos. Thank you so much for the radio.
Trying to find her. She's being full time pretty and welcome to the change together challenge game.
Oh no, the hag Maxine. Her hag's there with that. I'm 56, so.
Well, I'm a thousand years old. Well, shit, you got me beat.
Wow, very cool. Three, two, oh wait. Oh, oh, oh, yeah.
It's her. Hello. Thank you so much for the sub. Thank you. Thank you.
Three, two, one. Blast off. Blast off, three, two, one. Blast off, three, two, one. Blast off.
All right. Okay, perfect. Wait, where the fuck are we going? This way.
Oh, in here. Oh, there's up here, up here. This way. Oh, it's another ladder. I'm being,
she's called on. Hold on. She's clipped through the wall. Come back around.
I can't move. There are chains turned silver. I swear they were black earlier.
Hello, everybody. I am Apollo. Thank you so much for following me. I am the goddess of music.
Oh, this one's gonna be a killer and a bitch. Sorry. No, no, you're fine. This is gonna be a killer.
Look at that. Oh, all right. We did it before when they were. All right. So we just got to run and jump.
Or die. That's all so good. We're fine. We're fine. We're fine.
Back off from those lasers. I'm crying.
I can't. Okay, I'm pulling. I'm pulling. Move back. Move back.
That actually helped us. I think we're still going. Yeah, we're still, we're still in it. We're still in it.
I'm up. I'm up. I'm up. I'm up. I'm back down. I'm up.
Oh, she's loop-jumped her. Wait, I wonder if this will be to our advantage. Can we jump?
Yeah. Let's try it. Let's try it. Ready? Ready? Let's go.
Let's get closer. Let's go. Jump. It's fine. We're good. We got the hack, bros.
We're just looping around. Wait, if Rhea jumps over. No, I just have to do good.
It's fine. I'm backing up. I was trying to run away from it.
The struggle is real. We're so math flying.
All right. I mean, we did do it like that though. Like run and jump. One on the side
and then one in the middle. We've got this. Let's do it. Okay. Cool. Run. Run. Jump again.
No, if you sprint. I think we should run. I think we should run with it and then jump
over and let's come back. I agree, you're a strat.
Okay.
We're going to wait for it. Let's come back.
Oh, yeah, let's go.
Pro gamer.
Over here.
Okay.
Can we make this?
Yeah.
Oh, we did.
Okay.
Just wait.
I hear it to the other jumping pad over there.
That's fine.
We got this.
Go.
What?
What's happening?
Now we just got it.
Jumped in.
Come on.
Hail.
Why?
Oh, it has actually worked out.
Oh, don't let go.
I'm not letting go.
Wow.
This is a beautiful mountain gelmere.
You got Mordor over there.
Damn.
Where'd the guy go?
Oh, he's all the way down there.
Now look at him.
Oh, here's the screams of the dams.
Oh, there he is.
Fly, you fools.
No, fly more.
You can let go.
It'll automatically drop us.
Oh, the car.
Oh, we got a car.
Oh, well.
Allo.
Have fun.
I like how this guy always is just like,
if you move your mouse around,
he just like goes to the opposite.
I love you.
Okay.
Here you go.
Zoom through it.
Ah!
She hesitated.
Hesitation means death.
Where'd the car go?
Hesitation is the thing.
So, who's turn is the next?
I'm ready to drive this flight.
Go for it.
Here we go.
I'm so ready for Fran.
Well, I love her.
Drive the song.
You're the queen.
She was gonna drive the song.
Never let Apollo drive.
What do you mean?
Never let Fran drive.
Okay, Azera.
Azera, you're next.
Azera, drive.
No Fran, don't touch it yet.
I'm not.
Clicky, clicky, clicky.
Azera, you got this.
To the left, to the left turn.
Alright, Apollo might have to be the one
that drives us.
Why is the turn so long?
It's hard to steer.
Wait, what do you steer with?
I don't know.
At the AD.
Oh, okay.
Oh, my God.
The AD is AD.
She's always just A and B.
Okay.
A and D and...
I wonder if you know how to live in Tokyo
if you see it and you need it
and you know you got to go
faster than you.
To the left, to the left slowly.
Rose, it's alright.
I'm a pro.
Come back, come back.
The AD is real.
I didn't think you...
Okay, okay.
We're fine.
We're good.
You're a pro.
Pro-stress.
Oh, my God, oh, my God.
We made it, boys.
We made it.
Years of Mario Kart.
Owned my skill.
Now this part, we just got to time it
to what the direction is.
We shouldn't be too hard, I believe.
And we just got, you can just jump.
Yeah, I want to get closer.
We just jump on it and kind of do it.
We just jump until it turns because, yeah.
Okay.
And go.
And jump.
There you go, there you go.
We're back, we're back.
And jump.
There's a weird version of dance, dance, revolution.
For some reason.
Oh, shit, oh, shit, oh, shit.
I tried to recover it, I tried.
Oh, wait.
Oh, we're back here?
Oh, okay.
Oh, we missed our ride.
Well, hey, it's okay.
Oh, wait, let's go back.
And go.
Wait, we're going back.
Wait, are we going back?
No, we're going to the right spot.
Oh, for a second it glitched out for me.
And I was like, we what?
Oh, hello.
I can't get about it.
Okay, jump, jump, jump.
Oh, perfect. There we go.
Got it, got it, got it, got it.
Hello, thank you so much for coming.
I'm getting like, super pulled here.
I'm sorry.
I have no control over what I do.
Sign in, sign.
We just got back.
We just got to climb up.
Oh, is this just jumping?
Okay, jump.
If one of us can't make it, we just kind of pull them.
Yeah, the rest of us can make it.
We got this.
Oh, oh, I'm falling.
Okay, no, we're good, we're good, come on.
Pull me up, pull me up, bro.
Pull me up, bro.
Yippee.
Move over here.
Wait, just kidding.
Oh, my God.
Oh, you can jump on the corners.
Oh, okay, that makes it a lot easier.
Can I pull Azura?
Okay.
Thank you.
So we can just jump up onto the corner?
Yeah.
Yeah?
Sometimes it lets me.
All right, when you guys are free,
can you pull?
Pull here, pull over here.
Yay, I made it.
Why am I stuck under?
All right, perfect.
Perfect.
Yeah.
How are you able to do that?
I was able to do it once
and then I couldn't do it again.
I think only two people can do it at a time.
I am dead.
There we go, there we go, there we go.
One of these flames of fire.
Where do we go next?
We go that way?
All right.
One.
Oh, God.
This is just jumping, this will be easier.
Azura, lead the way.
Me, why me?
Because you get pulled around by us,
so it's your turn to pull us.
Why am I off to the side?
I am always standing sideways.
Any home?
What?
It's a small jump, it's a small jump.
You got to go push and then back.
Push back.
Oh, no.
Okay, okay, okay.
It's all over you.
No!
I couldn't pull you off.
Okay, so when you're jumping,
push and then back.
You got to pull back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Three, two, one.
Are we just going for it?
Small jumps, small jumps.
Three, two, one.
Okay, we got it.
Oh, shit.
I slid off.
We are doing so good.
We can do it again.
Okay, okay.
We've got this.
Okay, okay, okay.
Who's the best gamer sub?
Use code up.
Go on.
Yeah.
Code, yum.
Yum, yum.
Code TV.
What is happening?
Oh, gaming.
This is pretty cool actually.
I feel like I'm doing double Dutch.
Do, do, do, do.
Little dunce, doo dunce, doo dunce, doo dunce,
doo dunce, doo dunce.
Doo dunce, doo dunce.
Ah, I'm out of breath.
Okay, are you yeah ready?
Three, two, one!
I got her!
My cat's food is going off!
Wow!
Ow...
about looking at this disappointment.
Damn!
Don't go out and do me like that.
We trying.
Come here, Bea.
I'm gonna bring my cat to her food bowl.
Yeah.
Come here, you go fish meal.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Sorry, my cat's legs don't work.
She's fine.
I got her to her food bowl.
Do you just throw up?
What?
Oh, there we go.
Poles are close to me.
Yeah.
I want to be so close to you.
Oh, I want to be close.
So close.
That's so sexy.
I love a woman that can just burp into my face.
I like that.
Smells like Gamer Sub's lean.
I love it.
And it's really funny because my cat just jumped off the screen.
Oh, I'm dead.
OK.
I'm ready.
We ready?
Ready.
Three, two, one.
Oh, he jumped off the car.
No, it's good.
I can get on this limb.
Oh, thank you.
Oh.
I'm going to need you to.
Oh, well.
Pfft.
Oh, no.
Yeah, I got to my chat.
I got Fia's meds today.
So hopefully that goes away soon.
She gets like this weird virus where her body is just like,
I can't walk.
But she should be good after some antibiotics.
She's a tough one.
I love her to death.
She's my little baby girl.
All right.
Three, two, one.
Baby steps, baby steps.
Oh, oh, there we go.
There we go.
Three, two, one.
This looks like tofu.
OK, OK, OK.
OK.
Three, two, one.
OK, OK.
Oh, shit.
Two, zero.
Get to the other side.
Let me swing.
Is there a don't move so much?
Ah, I'm not swinging anymore.
I'm not swinging anymore.
Guys, don't move.
Swingings, are you swinging?
I'm just constantly pulling.
I'm not swinging anymore.
All right, all right, there we go.
Stay calm.
Stay calm, collected.
Freya, don't.
Oh, that actually worked out.
I made it.
Yeah, let's jump across.
Then that gives us some more room.
Yeah, it's your sensitivity, so why?
You just fly off the platform when you get up.
OK, ready?
Ready?
Really bad at video games.
Three, two, one.
That was a little early.
Speedcore.
Speedrun, go.
Oh, never mind.
Speedrun is not in my speedrun.
OK, OK.
I like how far the stairs are to follow.
Oh, jeez.
I'm trying to pull.
Oh, all right.
Woo.
OK.
Nice count.
What is this?
We were so unified before.
Easy jump.
We've got this.
Easy.
Easy jump.
Oh, no, this next thing was.
Pause.
Oh, never mind.
We're fine.
OK, we just got out of there.
This has to be timing.
Ready?
Here we go.
Get closer, Sarah.
Go.
Wait.
I don't think we did a good job.
Oh.
I am fine.
Oh, never mind.
Yippee.
OK, OK, OK.
Let's do that again.
Get closer, everyone.
Everyone, Azora.
Azora, honey.
OK.
Wait.
Jump.
Why did I overshoot that?
I don't understand.
Well.
Oh, we're fine.
We're fine.
OK, we just need to pull them up and quickly.
No.
Jump.
Oh, make it to that one.
Next one.
Smart.
All right.
Where do we go now?
Which way are we going?
I'm trying to climb.
Wait.
OK, OK.
Oh, we're back to the top.
All right.
Go.
This way?
Oh.
It's fine.
Dude, this is so fun.
No.
Oh, my God.
All right.
OK, OK, OK.
We got a speed run this.
Yeah.
OK, ready?
Shift the sprint.
Got it.
Jump.
Ready.
Oh, what the heck?
Yeah, me too.
I think you jump farther when you sprint.
We don't sprint until the jump is made.
OK.
I agree.
I don't know what's happening.
I'm just kind of just hanging out.
Oh.
Oh, I got us.
Wait.
We're going to be head down.
OK.
I guess no shift yet until when your feet are on the ground.
Got it.
Yeah.
OK.
Next one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
OK.
Let's do this.
And go.
And oh.
Oh.
Yeah.
Carry us.
Carry us to victory queen.
We found out.
Oh.
We did it.
Yeah.
I was late.
I thought I was going to mash this all up because of that.
All right.
Oh, what's that?
What the heck?
Oh, it's a timer.
Oh.
Oh, we already lost that.
Yeah.
I think we got it.
Should we try that again?
Hold on.
OK.
So like when we're climbing, we got to try to jump as fast.
All right.
We'll try to shift.
We're going to use less time.
Yeah.
Actually, I think we can make that.
What is this?
OK.
I'm back.
Here we go.
Yeah.
Oh.
Go.
I don't know if we're going to make it, guys.
We're making it.
We're making it, guys.
We did it.
Yeah.
It was hard to avoid the climbing animations.
Help.
Oh, my God.
That was scary.
Thanks, Queen.
We did it.
Apollo with the clutch.
Yeah.
Apollo with the hard carry.
Ready?
Go.
Nice.
Right off.
Right.
I counted us off and missed.
There we go.
Thank you.
OK.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
Nifty.
Three.
Oh.
All right.
Three.
Oh, my God.
An elevator.
Thanks, the lords.
No.
I think you have an elevator.
It's OK.
You'll just hang around.
Yeah.
It's cool.
I'm fine.
I'm just going to chill.
It's like running in midair.
Oh.
Yay.
Oh, you guys are going to be stuck.
No, they're not stuck.
You're fine.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Come around.
Come around the side.
Come around the...
Go to the opposite side for you.
Go to the opposite side.
We've got you.
No, we've got you.
Oh, it broke.
It doesn't matter.
Oh, OK.
OK.
What's happening?
Pull them up.
Yeah.
What the hell is that?
Oh.
This is fun.
We're like one third of the way there.
We're almost done.
Yay.
Holy crap.
I'm impressed with this.
No deaths.
Azora and I are going to like plan to play this again in like Saturday, but we're going
to be drunk.
Oh, God.
Oh, my goodness.
How do you die?
Can you die?
I can't.
I just kind of went down.
All right.
Yeah.
If you look down and go down.
Cool.
Yeah.
I'm excited for that.
Honestly impressed with the level design.
I'm not going to lie.
Yeah.
When I play Diablo.
Hello Raiders.
Hi.
Hello.
Hi Raiders.
Hi sisters.
Hi.
Sorry.
Oh, my God.
Hi sisters.
I love that.
The jump scare.
This is the third fate.
Hades.
Siri.
And Nico now.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
It's an honor.
We're playing chain together with a lovely, beautiful guest.
Fraya.
And Siby.
Siby.
Dule.
I'm so sorry.
I'm Dule now.
Dule.
I'm Siby Cottonbom.
And Siby Cottonbom.
Yes.
Hi.
What the hell is this?
I hope the collab is going well.
It's going very well.
Oh, wait.
Wings.
Get the wings.
Where?
Wings.
I've never been this far.
Ah.
Is this really only the second wings? Have we missed some?
Oh, uh, probably.
Oh.
Yeah, I don't know how he's supposed to find all 10.
Oh, anyways.
Oh.
What's the puzzle?
We've got this.
Mavikins, can we please have a shout-out to Hoda?
I'm going to make you a VIP.
Hee hee hee hee.
Is this our final one?
How do you-
What?
Over there.
How do we-
Oh, OK.
I'll just uh-
No, no.
Someone has to stay on the end.
OK.
So the two on the end go to the end.
I'll stay.
I'll stay right here then.
OK, then she beat go to the other one.
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
OK.
Are we missing one?
And then what happens?
Are there more buttons?
Oh, there's one up there.
It's time.
Ah!
Oh, where is it?
Times.
Over here, where I am.
Oh, that's bad.
Oh, it's up top.
Damn.
Are we supposed to do that?
Yeah, it looks like we got to get to the little one.
All right.
And then we got to show.
OK.
All right.
Is it really timed or-
Maybe it's timed.
Maybe they're just on.
Yeah.
I hope so.
Right?
No.
Go.
Oh.
Wait, no.
Oh, there's another one up there.
Oh, my God.
Also, this isn't the right way.
OK.
It's this.
I think it's this way to the left side.
Is it tossed around?
This way?
Yeah.
I think-
Yeah, there we go.
It was tossed around in a rag doll.
What is going on?
OK.
Over here.
Climb.
Ah!
OK, OK.
OK.
She just runs off every time.
OK, OK, OK.
OK.
Over there.
Jump over here.
Over here.
You-
You went the hardest way.
OK.
Oh!
I'm trying so hard not to fall off right now.
You pressed the button, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, I already pressed it.
Now we just need to get to the other side.
Come on.
All you Azura.
Ah!
Perfect.
I need you.
Pull me, pull me.
Trying.
It's-
There we go.
I was pulling Azura towards me.
No problem, no problem.
I don't think it has been an hour in this room.
I already got three raids.
That's pretty crazy.
OK, this one, this one.
Wee!
We did it!
You're-
We're free, we're free.
What?
We did it, yeah.
I see, we did it.
Oh.
Uh oh.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
OK, now jump.
Oh!
Fine, we can just carry you.
Thank you.
Oh, thank you.
That was a little thingy.
Uh oh.
OK, we gotta time it.
How close should we get?
Let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go.
I'm not so sure about that, chief.
OK, now we go, now we go.
OK, let's wait, wait here.
Whoa, my toesies.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
OK.
All right.
OK, go.
I feel like Spider-Man.
I think I'm the slowest out of all of us.
Oh, jump.
Oh.
Wee.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, stairs.
Wow.
Oh, that was easy.
Wee!
Talk to me in sexy voice.
Is Mama Freya live?
Oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Sorry.
OK.
She had to sprint through.
Yeah, I believe so, ready.
And, oh, I just jumped.
OK.
Oh, I'm like are y'all here?
Azura is skirting the edge.
I have to walk the way.
You can't skip walking into it.
I have to walk into the bridge.
I don't want to pull, yeah, yeah, I don't want to pull.
I am live.
Yeah, boy, OK.
Hold on tight, spider monkey.
Got it.
There you go.
Where you been, Loka?
I'm down.
I'm pulling you.
There you go.
I think I figured out how to pull now.
Yeah.
Oh, man, I like what Apollo just dangled there.
Dangled to victory.
Ready?
Jump across.
We jump.
Ready?
Jump.
I got a jump here.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, I'm scared.
We all just backed up at the same time.
Ready?
I'm scared.
Ah!
I'm so scared.
I'm so straight on it.
Sorry.
Oh, nice.
We're in a good spot.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm going to have lost my voice after this.
Same.
It's gone.
I have ASMR stream tomorrow, so I guess I'm just
going to have a horse voice.
Hi, everybody.
OK, ready?
I'm going.
I'm facing my fears.
And go!
Oh, you just missed that Apollo.
My space bar was like, it didn't click.
They almost panicked.
OK.
It's hard to see past these stupid bars.
You got it.
Where are we going now?
Where are we going this way?
Oh, wait.
Are we not supposed to get off?
I don't think so.
We can go this way.
Yeah, I think this is an area you fall at.
Like, if you fall, you can land here in one of these areas.
Also, we weren't supposed to jump off.
OK, so we just jumped back off.
I think we went the wrong way.
OK.
Sorry, I have to go in that direction over there.
You got right there on our left.
OK, we're supposed to go over there.
OK, ready?
Yeah.
Oh.
I got on me.
Thank you so much for that.
I blame Apollo.
You can blame me.
It was all bait.
Thank you so much for the raid.
So nice weather we're having.
Yeah, gorgeous hellscape.
Oh, yeah, I love it.
I kind of like it.
It wouldn't be a hell unless we were chained together,
though.
If we were separate, it would be just a vacation home,
honestly.
So because we're chained together, it's hell.
Mm-hmm.
OK, don't.
Oh, I'm laughing too hard.
Sorry, that was me.
Right on it.
Oh, it's neat.
Where are we?
Oh, what is this?
What's this pit?
There's like a hole in there.
Go to the hole.
We find a secret spot.
Oh, that's the water where we were.
Hey, thank you so much for the raid.
Welcome.
Hell is my kind of place.
Yeah, we are playing.
Oh, Missouri is pulling us.
Beautiful ladies of Veilor and Apollo.
Hi.
I am from Mythos.
OK.
Apollo, if we were.
I think it's the only up.
Sorry, it's called chained together.
That too.
If we were goddesses in Mythos, what would our goddess names
be?
Which Greek gods would it be?
Let's see.
Azora would be Aphrodite.
Oh, that's a good one.
Do we have to go over here?
Because she's just she's so freaking adorable.
I could see it like a shy Aphrodite be like.
Hey, we're fine.
We're fine.
I don't see this is good.
We got tossed up here.
Now we go back on it.
Three, two, one.
Too far.
Yeah, we got to wait for the next one.
Don't we go?
Don't we go over there?
Looks like a point.
Over there.
OK, ready?
Ready?
Jump.
How did I not land on that?
OK, we got to go the opposite way over there, I believe.
Why not?
Where are we trying to go?
Right here?
Is that our jump?
I would say Aris from Aris.
Yeah, Aris would be cool.
I think Artemis for Frio would be cool.
You got jump on that.
Oh, shit.
We got to time it.
OK, count.
Three, two, one.
OK, ready?
Ready?
Jump.
Count.
Three, two, one.
OK, I don't know how that happened, but I did it.
This guy stopped moving.
Guy stopped moving.
I'm pulling, pulling, pulling, pulling, pulling, pulling.
I'm trying to stabilize.
OK, cool.
I'm going to get pulled off with a circle.
All right, we're good.
We good, we good.
OK.
Nifty.
Oh, we got to go.
OK, now don't kick that.
You're ready to go.
There it was.
We did it.
OK, OK, OK.
I got so discombobulated.
Where the heck are we?
Yeah, which way are we going?
Oh, my gosh, I saw a flaming man as.
Where?
Oh.
Look at his butt.
So there's another one coming up.
We've got to get to that one.
All right.
Let's get closer.
Get close.
Yeah.
Ready?
Go.
It's helpful if you shout when you jump.
Is this where we're going?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This one, this one.
Yeah.
There we go.
Oh, OK.
Good job.
Yippee.
Totally not late for Mickey is raiding the bar.
Hello.
Hey, guys, doing back there.
Are you ready to jump off this hard wood?
Yes.
Do we have to jump?
Oh, my God.
There we are.
OK.
Go forward, Apollo.
Oh, I just fell onto it.
I didn't even jump like I said, I should have.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Oh, I hear a waterfall.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
No, no, no, no, no.
You got us.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
When we go big time.
I've got you.
all right yes I'm very excited you know Azura keep with that strat and just walk
across like that here I'll go this way all right oh it's this hello we don't
teleport us yet there has to be wings here are we in a secret area oh I see
something over there be the way oh over here there's a there's a overware oh what
is that oh wait this is huh I don't think this is a place to lay where we're
the elevator is and then the water yeah yeah oh that that was I thought those
ruins nevermind oops Daisy bang all right take us back
take us back not again damn it okay three two I got pulled back you're fine
actually I'm good you guys can jump over this oh no oh my god oh my god oh here
we go why can't I get on this thing okay I am taking sanity damage from this
game yeah oh do we all just disconnect what just happens I lost she be I lost
she be did Azura just crash oh no I'm just a small thing all by myself over
here over here look at the opposite way I messed it up I thought I could make it
to do what you must Azura actually my finger move by itself and I was like wait
why I didn't crash I think she be crossed she be you cross oh I crash oh maybe
it was just me that crash that I thought I really was crashed run a bag hold the
line everybody hold the line my internet was like halt
she be come back what are we gonna do with it come back to me come back okay
we might have to restart vtube studio hola everybody bring her back pray she be
come back I cast extremely slow internet I cast no you're casting
extremely slow internet on me and I'm like you know what I cast a reverse
card she cast a reverse on me low yes I did yes I did baby yes I did I can't
see my cat seven more followers and I'll hit 9k baby oh yeah okay I'm
joining I'm disconnecting okay okay I'm connecting hi Apollo I love your mother
hi baby thanks so much I'm gonna be cool baby I'll call you baby do you want me
to send you more audios then she got I didn't get audio never you Chad only for
hot ladies here whoa Freya coming in hot I need I need to rearrange everybody don't
worry guys don't worry sun drafts you're gonna get audios here soon I got a
really nice spicy one it's called hello master oh my god what is happening we're
gonna we're gonna rearrange nobody look nobody look at the beautiful women on
screen everybody a virtualize what Apollo's head is so damn big yes it is
Big hit at, and then Freya's just got some humongous bazoinga goings.
Are we back?
Yeah.
You good?
You dying?
Yeah, I'm Gucci.
I'm not dying.
We're soaring.
Dying.
We're just falling to hell.
Cause everything's out of reach.
Free falling.
Alright, I'm good.
I almost put save and quit game.
Do not.
Do not quit the game.
Beautiful cue of that random man screaming to death.
Alright.
Here we go.
We're back.
Our heads are so big.
Let's go.
It's blocking the screen.
Hold on.
We're not ready.
Nobody else wants just me and you apologize.
What?
We've got it.
I'm pulling you.
I need to make a smaller.
I'll do that while we're screaming.
That was fine.
Hello.
Thank you so much.
Thanks so much for following, honey.
Is there an Apollo or like on top of each other?
We're moving.
Is there over a little bit?
Do you want to be on top or do you want to be on bottom?
Want to be on top.
Sorry to sort of.
I like to be in between.
Son of America's TechSop model.
Yeah.
I'm ready to jump.
Go on.
Go.
Okay.
We're doing good.
We've got this.
Sound like you just came.
Jump.
Twas not high.
That is all I will say.
This is funny.
Are you enjoying yourselves, guys?
Yippee.
Oh.
We're doing good.
Are you enjoying yourselves, guys?
Yippee.
Oh.
What the heck?
I can't take it off.
I think I'm getting mind broken as this continues.
Whoa.
Okay.
I'm moving back a little bit.
Back of the front.
Kind of like hugs me up.
Azora.
I didn't think she was going to move.
Okay.
Ready?
There's another one coming up, guys.
Over here.
She was locked in.
Go.
Oh, my God.
She just made that Apollo menu.
Here comes another one.
Oh, look.
Hey, closer, ladies.
Go, go, go.
Oh, shit.
Oh, what?
What?
Your guys' models are gone for me.
Apollo, you're gone.
Oh, Apollo just died.
I'm dead.
Jump to freedom.
Damn.
All right.
Let's pause here.
Apollo, come here.
Hi, guys.
You in chat.
You guys doing okay, chat?
You guys doing all right?
Damn.
Am I gone?
Hello?
Well, you're still here.
We're just kissing you on VTube Studio.
Yeah.
I can't see you guys either.
I'm bad.
You might have crashed like I did.
Oh, connection system.
Okay.
Ehe, ehe, ehe.
Hydrate time.
Good idea.
One by one, they're dying.
Damn.
We start my model.
Sheesh.
Oh, my gosh.
Remember to have encrustables.
Big stretch.
What is happening?
I'm sorry.
I just got, I just let it out.
I was like, oh my God.
I was cute.
And I ended up just like.
Sometimes you got a stretch.
It feels good.
Connection to steam servers failed.
Oh no.
That's what I got to.
I got that too.
I had to restart.
Oh, like to restart steam.
I did that already.
Oh, then yes.
I like horse clothes it on the end of your arm.
Oh, wait.
Oh, oh, it's connected.
It's connected.
Yeah.
Welcome, baby.
Let's see it.
Baby.
What the hell?
Who the fuck is that?
A ghost.
Ghosts just whispers in your ear.
Hey, baby.
How you doing, baby?
I'm taking a shit, baby.
Oh, fuck yeah.
That's the best feeling man.
Tell me more.
Hey, vengeful baby.
How you doing?
Steam saying a bunch of failures.
I'm done.
I'll talk like a really bad southern bed.
I'll talk like a really bad southern bell until Apollo gets back.
Did it say it failed?
It said that you rejoined.
I saw it.
Hello.
I'm here.
I was wondering if after all this years.
I was like me.
I was literally about to start singing that.
You took the words right out my mouth.
I was going to be so insulted by my southern accent.
I am.
She's fuming quietly.
Bonjourno.
Konichiwa.
Moshi moshi.
Are we got to go Zyma?
I'm carrying.
What the heck?
I can't see.
There we go.
Make it stop.
You haven't loaded back in for me yet.
It's probably going to take a bit.
She's coming.
She came.
She's here.
Look at the musical notes.
They're animated.
All the mythos girls are.
Their outfits are also pretty animated.
I can control her guys.
Look.
Look at her feet.
Hold up.
I'm making myself big.
Those are actually some really nice feet.
They're not weird vtuber feet.
Some vtubers have weird ass feet.
You have nice feet.
Get stuffed on over here.
Get stuffed on over there.
I'll put you back.
I can't stop staring at these toes.
These are nice.
Oh my god.
My mods are going to yell at me later.
I'm so sorry.
The grapefruit.
That's why I learned that technique.
I learned the grapefruit technique.
Here we go.
We're back.
We're back at it again.
Back and better than ever.
I'm being pulled.
Let's go.
I'm coming.
She's coming.
Yeah?
I'm being pulled.
I'm being pulled to victory.
What just happened?
I saw the jump and I was like,
oh shit, I did the same.
Please.
Oh no.
We have to literally be super good at this man.
I'm going to kill myself in Minecraft.
In Minecraft?
They were talking about them dogs.
Yeah, I'm all fucking feed, man.
They're beautiful.
Them dogs are barking.
I got that dog in me.
My neighbors are probably like,
what the fuck is going on?
I'm sure they always think that.
Not just today.
Okay, I got it.
I'm ready.
I don't know.
Is chain together carrying my motion sickness right now?
Wait, whoa.
I'm trying.
I could have turned around to pull up.
Last time, your nieces and nephews were into that.
Damn bright they are.
Sweet home out, man.
Listen, I don't kink shame here.
You like feet, you like feet.
That's it.
I thought we were talking about
kissing sisters.
Are you from Mississippi?
Because you're the only miss who's pissed.
I'm sippy.
Okay, baby, I'll get a cup.
Give me some of that.
Is that how you piss?
You just make those noises?
Sorry, I fucked that up and jumped too early.
No, we're good, we're good.
We're good, I got you.
Yeah, lift me up.
Up you go.
You ready?
Okay, I'm doing it.
Are we all wearing the same pants?
Why do we have all the ripped
golden hole in our butt cheek?
Go slow.
I'm sprinting this.
No, no.
Slow and steady.
Easy tap, easy tap.
Easy clap, easy tap.
One at a time, jump.
One at a time.
Altogether?
I don't think so.
Okay, let's do it.
You don't have to jump.
You can just fall, by the way.
No, no, no.
Okay, okay.
It's very hard to pull her up
for some reason.
I have to be looking down at her.
Three, two, one.
Oops.
We made it, we made it, we made it.
Going without us, just go, just go.
Dammit, dammit, dammit, dammit.
Dammit, dammit, dammit.
Oh my god.
I'm just going to walk on to this.
I'm so tired.
Okay, good, okay, next.
Freak.
Oh shit, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
We got it, we got it, we got it.
Okay, okay, okay.
We're going, we're going.
Dammit, oh snap.
Yeah, we're so good, we're so good.
No, we're going.
Why do I keep fucking jumping?
That was so early.
Jump button to jump.
Okay, hold up, hold up, hold up.
Hold up, I got to fix him.
Ah!
It's fine, you're fine, you're fine.
We got this, we're going to carry you.
Oh no.
We've got you, we can carry you.
And Kat just hopped on my desk.
I jumped first, you jumped first.
I don't know what happened there.
I didn't see any of us touch it.
I forgot about the jump.
I forgot that it existed.
Where am I going?
Oh, where are we?
At the top of the water one again.
Okay, let's go.
Okay.
I didn't press the jump button.
You just jumped off.
I just ran off.
We got this, we got this.
Oh, I got a piss.
I got a piss.
I'm looking at this guy's ass.
Some fiery ass.
Don't get distracted by the ass.
It's very hard not to.
That's Hell's ass right there.
Oh, we made it, we made it, we made it.
Did we?
Oh god.
Don't speak so soon.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Hang on, hang on, hang on.
Open up, Haram.
Is it just me?
Where did my sound go?
Oh no.
Your game sound?
Oh, it disappeared.
That's weird.
Why is Apollo so down?
Hold on.
I need to fix Apollo's head.
It's doing inappropriate things.
Alright, I brought her back up.
That's my default height.
Damn.
It's a tiny hill.
I'm tiny.
I'm in chibi form.
Oh, that makes more sense then.
Yeah.
Oh, I just, what the?
No, no, no.
No, not again.
Okay, I'm going last.
Okay.
Single file.
Single file line, let's go.
There's no stuff, we're reconnecting.
We're reconnecting, no worries.
Oh wait, what just happened?
Where'd everybody go?
Oh wait, did everybody go?
Yeah, everyone left me.
Alright, who cares?
I'm not going to fall.
I'm just putting my Fuji up.
Fuji.
Oh, that's the game.
I need...
Hello, thank you so much for following.
Oh, there's something apparently wrong with steam.
That makes sense then.
Why does it news to mess up while we are playing?
How dare they?
Believe.
You're all free now.
We're not free, we're not free.
Now I'm just going to be a muppet on your screen,
so I hope you guys like that.
Our meds ran out.
We're just doing it how we are.
Bye-bye to those leaving.
Bye.
I can give you a link.
It's a really quick setup.
You just download it.
Do you want it?
I can't download something right now.
We've got to play the game.
We have priorities.
That's playing the game.
How's the game going?
It's very...
It's very reminiscent of your name.
I'll be right back. I hear my cat outside.
Now let the cat in.
Let me check on my cat.
Oh, it's not my cat.
It's an outside cat that I like feeding every now and then.
And it cries whenever it wants food.
So I go out there.
I'll be right back.
That's so good.
What?
Here, I look for you.
I give this to you.
What's up lady?
What?
I can't just do pictures of everyone.
That might be easier. Let's see who I have.
It's pictured here.
You just use this and then it uses the picture.
I got a fark discord with you.
Is this the discord pictures?
Okay, okay.
Yeah, it's whatever we put in there.
It will use whatever we have to open it.
So you don't have to change anything
or add anything yourself.
It will always be in there.
How do I join with you?
You just copy the group one.
Group, got it, got it, got it, got it.
And then you just add it as browser source.
Oh my God, it says I have to be using
the discord desktop app and I don't do that.
I use it in my browser.
You do?
You use the discord browser?
What'd I do?
That's funny.
It's just what I do.
I can still try to use it.
Does it still work though?
That's weird.
Is that gonna work?
I forgot I figured that out.
I stole this animation from Azura.
Oh.
What'd you steal from me?
Nothing.
We mean nothing.
What'd you steal from me?
What'd you over there looking at?
Nothing.
What'd you steal from me?
Mumble.
I just copied a certain animation.
I...
Um...
Yeah, this is not working.
This is not working for me.
Don't worry about it, we can still play.
Okay.
I give up, I couldn't figure it out.
Maybe if I give you the link,
can you still use the browser link that I give you?
Oh, try it.
We can see if that works.
Yeah, that's what I tried and it doesn't work.
It just shows a loading thing forever.
I couldn't figure out the breath part though.
The breath part is animated by the person who made it.
Yeah, I know what you're doing.
I see you there.
You're naughty.
I won't keep my eyes on you.
Just throw the thumbnail in there.
Oh, that's a good idea.
That's a good idea.
You want it?
What the thumbnail?
Don't...
Why are you saying it like that?
Yes, mommy, I want it so...
Mommy, please, mommy.
What?
No.
You're so lucky.
Why, why, why?
Why, uh...
Stam is not working.
And I'm not on your screen anymore.
I added a really fun toggle.
Oh, yeah.
There, look, I've got everyone.
Perfect.
I need to make a toggle where I can take off my shabari ropes.
There, I've got everyone now.
You still thumbed out.
I loved it.
Yeah, there we go.
OK, I'm ready, I'm ready.
It's beautiful.
It's all of us.
Absolutely stunning.
Oh, I love it.
Oh, I also figured out, I have...
Where is it?
I have these eyes.
And I didn't even know I had them.
What do you mean you didn't know you had them?
It didn't show up in any of my toggles.
I was digging through the toggle files when I got my new tan toggle.
And I was like, oh, where did this come from?
I know a lot of them weren't set up as cue lines or even me.
Yeah.
Hello, I'm back.
All right, are we ready?
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm back, I'm back, I'm back.
Turns out, I thought it was one of the black cats, whiskers.
I named it whiskers.
But there's a new cat.
And I was like, oh, and she's so pretty.
I was like, oh my God, I want to call you Sapphire.
I'm basically now feeding nine cats.
Oh my gosh.
I'm a cat lady.
We love it though.
I aspire to be that level of cat lady.
My Lord Apollo, leshing guys.
I love cats, okay?
Where you going lady?
Yeah, it's this way.
Don't go that way.
She's like, let's go that way.
Where am I going?
She'll go that way.
Oh, shit.
This way.
Is there, are you ready?
We're starting.
We're going, we're going.
She's not ready.
Stop.
Okay, ready, ready, ready, ready.
Oh, okay.
I'm very strong.
Finger action is on point.
Pinching forward.
Very carefully.
Okay.
Oh.
Just the, oh.
Oh my God.
Wait, what?
This is not it.
One at a time pulls the other's weight.
It makes a lot of noise.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh my God.
This is what breaks us, huh?
Yeah.
So close to the checkpoint.
I'm completely mind broken at this point.
It's a part of the old cat lady.
Yes.
What the hell is that?
Is that you?
Oh.
Oh, I made it this time.
Yay.
Okay.
Nice.
I jump with one.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Sometimes we may jump in like kind of different directions.
It will gank you.
So weird.
Yeah.
I mean, it's still kind of glitches through.
So that's, oh my God.
Yeah.
Is that you?
No, that's a circle.
Oh.
I would definitely make that noise though.
Okay.
Here we go.
Let's be careful and carefully make the jump.
Okay.
Careful jump.
Okay, ready?
One, two, three.
You guys can, you can just fall onto it.
I don't know for this one if you can do that though.
This one we can jump.
One, two, three.
Nope, you can't.
So I figured out you can't.
Okay.
I feel like I'm playing Elden Ring.
I've been waiting this entire time for like a boss monster to come out and do this.
Totally depressed.
What is happening?
I tried to jump and it didn't jump.
Oh my God.
Oh, I was not paying attention at all.
Okay.
How could this happen to me?
I remember seeing me when I said I was worried about you.
I remember seeing me.
What?
What are you saying?
No, I didn't hear you.
What?
I said remember seeing me and I was worried about you and you're like, I shouldn't have been worried about you.
That wasn't even me.
I'm letting you dangle there for that.
No, don't pull her up for it.
Whatever, I'm leaving.
I'll pull her up so she has to make the jump.
We were never making it past this point.
Where the fuck am I?
He just jumped off.
Oh, nice.
Thank you so much for the raid.
Welcome in.
Do the lighting change.
My cat is behind my monitor.
Reina, why have you betrayed me?
Okay, this time we've got it.
This is the one.
I am the one.
I didn't touch it.
I'm killing myself.
I'm hanging myself right here.
Hello.
Hello and goodbye if you come and left or if you're just coming in.
Okay, ready?
Yeah, it's actually Reina this time.
Go.
Go, go, go.
Oh.
I can't slip and fall.
No.
You fucking suck.
How can you do that?
You can't slip and fall and I said it and boom.
It works.
I didn't see anybody land on that that time.
That was weird on my screen.
I think it's never good.
Never get up.
Speed run, speed run, speed run, speed run.
Speed run, speed run.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Perfect.
Look to the other side.
We got this.
Hello, family.
You're not alone.
What?
Nobody jumped.
I was like...
Oh, hey, we're fine.
Can I?
I mean, might as well just go to the checkpoint, man.
No, no, we don't from here.
We don't from here.
And then we go back on the one that we missed.
It's all right.
We're good.
I literally can't pull a Zer up unless I'm looking at her.
That's so weird.
So if I'm looking this way, I can't just pull.
I think you're supposed to be looking at them to pull them.
I had to...
Okay, ready?
Go!
Why did my space bar not work?
Oh, hey, we're back.
Never mind.
I'm a wizard.
I'm a wizard, guys.
Shit.
I wish to be a wizard right now and inhaling those fumes.
Go!
Okay, this is the last one and then I have to go.
Okay.
I can only do two hours, but this is the one we're going to make it.
We're making it.
We're making it for one.
I can feel it.
Perfect technique.
Beautiful.
Ready?
And jump!
I was too excited.
Thank you.
I'm locked in.
No.
Okay, okay, okay.
Look at that.
If I save right there, will it be saved?
No.
We're going to make the logs.
Damn.
Okay, yeah, we've got to make it to the next checkpoint.
We've got this.
I can't...
Oh, hello.
Thank you so much for the raid.
Hi.
Hello.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, this one you can just fall onto.
Okay.
Let's try.
I don't think so.
It's too far.
I think you have to do a jump.
Yeah, you can do a small jump.
Small jump.
Oh, no.
Okay, let me up.
Is there a...
It's because you pulled me down.
I didn't even fall.
What are you talking about?
Oh, so you do fall.
You do fall.
Okay.
You've got to fall.
Just fall and then climb.
Oh, my God.
Oh, me.
Okay.
So it is a fall thing.
It is a fall thing.
Okay, I think we figured it out.
We figured it out.
No more jumping when we get to the wood part.
You just fall and then climb.
Okay, one more.
This is it.
This is the one.
No.
I'm killing us all.
Come with me.
No.
Come on.
Death.
Here we go.
I'm sorry to follow.
Goodbye.
No.
How are you able to pull us all up the one time?
We're trying to kill ourselves, but then when we're trying to stay on, we all fall.
I have no idea.
I think it's because I'm on a flat platform and it's long enough.
Oh, that makes sense.
Hey, make a triangle.
This game is terrible.
Okay.
This is it.
This is the last one.
Okay.
We're almost at the two hour mark.
Oh, my God.
It fell.
Do not fall.
We got this.
Here we go.
Perfect.
Oh, we're amazing.
Okay.
Ready and jump.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
He saved me.
I got too pale.
I got too orange.
Okay.
Over here.
And jump this way.
Okay.
We made it.
Yeah.
Apollo.
Hello.
Okay.
No, chunky wide.
Yay.
Okay.
Jump on the first one and just fall on the second.
I thought it was fall.
Fall on the first one and jump on both of them.
Both of them.
I did fall.
Okay.
You can just fall.
Yeah.
You want to fall.
Okay.
I'm backing up.
Shit.
I couldn't make it back to the platform.
I was trying to back up to the platform.
Okay.
I don't know why I fell and then I clicked like space bar to climb up.
God.
Okay.
That was not the one.
I'm killing us.
Damn it.
Come here.
No, we're killing us.
It's over.
It's done.
That's happening here.
It's a game.
We can end here.
Okay.
Thank you so much for having me, guys.
I had so much fun
and I lost so much sanity.
I don't ever want to play this game again.
I did have a lot of fun.
This.
This was fun.
Oh, this was good.
I'm out of lunch, mom.
I didn't play this as straw.
This would be fun to play as straw.
They're her Scottish rage.
Good luck.
take bets on who's gonna throw up first when you're playing this when you're
drunk. Oh my god. Azora, I'm putting my bets on you.
Well, me. I'm gonna play with you first.
Yeah, I think so. How are we dying?
Yes, damn it.
You're slowly trying to kill us, sir.
No.
Let me die. Let me die.
I'm ending it. Why am I on top of that?
Thank you.
Oh, now they want to die. No, I'm not letting it happen.
I'm not letting this happen.
No, I get to die in our own terms.
It's my terms we get to die on.
Wee.
Wee. This is actually nice.
This is pretty nice.
Oh, fuck. Get me out of here. Get me out of here.
Get me out of here. Get me out of here.
Get me out of here.
Oh my god. I'm leaving.
Leaving the game.
Get me out of here.
I'm still on the call.
Why am I all the way down here?
Let me turn that down a little bit.
Hey.
Did you guys enjoy?
That was fun. I actually like that game a lot.
I definitely want to play it with Stradi.
It was going to be so funny. I miss you guys too.
I miss you guys so much.
Did you guys like my little surprise?
Yeah, blue.
And then you got tan toggle.
Although I kind of go blackface for a second.
Sometimes it happens. Sometimes it doesn't.
Yeah, see that time I didn't do it.
It's funny.
I locked my true form.
Yeah, I'll be honest with you.
So normally it looks like this
and I don't like the colors
because I just look like a red orc.
So I fixed it myself.
I'm like, this isn't tan. This is red.
But it colored my ears the way I wanted.
So because I'm...
This looks like I have a sunburn.
Yeah, it looks so red.
So I asked for less red undertones.
But I was just like, whatever, I'll do it myself.
I'll do it myself.
And then I have my cover up coming.
I actually like it with the red eyes.
I thought I would like it with the blue eyes more.
But I like it with the red eyes.
Now we just need tan lines.
Oh yeah, where all my shabari is.
I could actually probably do that
and make my shabari...
Like initially my shabari was lighter.
The shadows because of the underlying part of the model.
I don't know if you guys noticed,
my hair color changes too.
And I change the toggle.
My hair gets lighter.
Because it looks...
I think it looks a little bit better
with lighter blonde hair.
I'm a sucker for white hair and dark skin.
I'll be honest with you.
Although this is a little bit darker than I am.
But I like...
I probably would be more of a Zura's color
and then she would be more of my color.
But you know, we can always figure that out.
Strawberry blond.
Look at that, I just dye my hair.
That's Madam Secret.
I dye my hair...
red at the ends.
Don't tell anyone.
I'm naturally just normally blonde.
I'm a freaking Valyrian from House of the Dragon.
But let's talk.
How are you guys doing?
How are you guys feeling?
Let me look at my donos and stuff.
I wanted to give you guys more attention
for my first stream back.
But I wasn't able to do that.
So I apologize.
Let's see.
Thank you guys for all the remembers.
That's so nice.
I saw it like this.
I figured out what we're doing
for the monthly.
I'm not telling you yet.
Hee hee hee.
Thank you Grumbo for the $50 tip.
I can't stay for your return stream.
Take this and feel better.
That sounds so bad.
Take my money.
Feel better.
I actually feel...
Somebody in my Twitter comments recommended
this thing called Vertagon.
That they said that they're family member use.
So I'm like fuck it.
And I bought it on Amazon.
And it's actually really good.
I feel a lot better after only taking one pill.
It's like a little supplement.
I was falling over myself
at the grocery store with my mom.
She had to study me a couple of times.
I keep making myself bigger.
Thank you for the remembers.
I'm going to call them remembers.
Reherums.
R-X-S-E-J.
Thank you Mr. Black.
Silence. Appreciate you guys.
I miss you guys a lot.
Let me...
What the heck's going on in my stream?
It's like showing me stuff from like five minutes ago.
You look amazing as always.
Thank you darling.
Thank you.
Yeah, I don't know if...
I wonder if people
will be mad that I'm brown
or like...
Although it's funny because when I do my toggles
I forgot...
So that's top audio was muted.
But oh my goodness.
What the hell?
Um...
Uh...
Thank you Doki.
For the two hundo.
That was...
I didn't expect that.
Why are you guys so nice to me?
I don't understand.
I don't deserve this.
Stop!
I'm tired.
Don't give me your money.
Oh...
I miss my hundo so much.
Toggle is beautiful.
I'm so happy to see you streaming it.
I know. I'm so glad to be back.
I was dying.
I was going to stream again this morning.
Um...
Just for us.
My mom was like, oh, let's take you to the grocery store.
So I like...
Didn't do that. And then my mom's like, oh, I'm going to be late.
And I'm like, great.
I'm just strafing mom.
What the hell, mother?
Um...
But she says hi. She says...
She's very thankful you guys have been taking care of me.
Because I was telling you guys...
Telling her about that you guys got me like...
So my mom's like, oh, do you need any like...
Um...
Gatorade? I'm like, sorry.
They bought me PDLI.
And my mom's like, oh, do you need this?
I'm like, oh, they bought me curtains.
She's like, what the hell?
And I'm like, I don't...
I don't know what they do to deserve it.
They're just so kind to me.
And I love it. And I appreciate it.
Yeah, I got some groceries.
I spent quite a bit of change on groceries.
But...
Definitely I hadn't gone grocery shopping in like...
Two months.
I would get...
A few things here or there.
But I just never like actually went full on grocery shopping.
I got a crustables.
Although I forgot to...
Get some things. So I need to run to the store tomorrow, probably.
She didn't even pay for it, literally.
I was just like talking to her.
I'm like, yeah, I finally got the um...
Little set for the balcony that I wanted.
The patio set.
My mom's like, oh, that's nice.
And I'm like, oh, yeah, harem got that for me.
And she's just like...
What?
And I'm like, yeah, she's like...
Cheebie, that was a lot of money.
And I'm like, I don't know what the...
She's like...
Are you sure it's only audio you're doing?
I'm like, mom.
I'm only doing audio.
Incrustables tier list stream?
Oh, yeah, I should probably do that.
That'd be a good idea.
Whoo!
So eepy.
Although I slept a couple of times today,
but I was kind of off and on...
A week since...
What's it called?
Since this morning.
Let me fix my freaking eyeballs.
But thank you so much, Doki.
Does Mama Cotton Bomb want anything?
Mama Cotton...
I was gonna buy her...
Because she got some groceries too while she was with me.
And I was gonna buy her groceries for her.
My mom is a very proud woman
and she doesn't like taking things.
And she's just like...
I feel weird you buying my groceries,
so I'm buying for my own.
You literally don't have a job right now,
and you've taken care of me my entire life,
so let me just take care of you.
And she's still refused.
Um...
My dad...
My mom, like, ridiculed my dad
because she's just like, well, you know how your dad is.
He's always asking you to buy him takeout
and get him that expensive bourbon.
She's like, that's fine.
And I'm like, oh my god.
She's...
My mom's just not like that.
She's worked hard for everything,
so she's very proud like that.
That's... I aim to be just like her.
And my dad's like, oh!
My dad calls you my minions.
He's like,
so your minions get the hook up?
Can they get me that bourbon?
I'm like, dad, that bourbon was $2,000.
I finally looked at the price.
I didn't look up the price before,
and I'm like, you wanted my people
to buy a $2,000 bottle for you?
No!
That's just so fine!
He's like, I don't know.
I didn't know the type of money you were making.
I don't know. I don't know.
And I'm like, dad.
No, I'm not going to ask them to do that.
I'm like, you haven't even come on the stream yet
and you expect them to catch you.
He's like, okay, you're right.
I'm doing okay.
I'm still a little dizzy.
Actually, that stream wasn't as bad as I thought it would be
in terms of my dizziness.
But I woke up fine this morning
and I'm like, oh, yeah, it's probably gone.
And then as I kind of move throughout the day,
if I move too much,
if I move my head, I get dizzy.
So I think because I'm just moving my eyes
and I'm not moving my head,
because I'm not turning my head to look at the screen,
I'm just using my eyes,
then it makes it a lot easier.
Although, when I was doing this
as a joke a couple of times,
I was like, whoa!
How's Fia doing?
So it seems like Fia has...
So if you don't know, let me explain
what's going on with Fia.
So Fia is my cat.
She is a little over a year old.
She's like a year and a month or two.
She is my female...
One of my female classmates cat.
She's adorable.
This past March,
randomly,
I was...
This has happened during my PL
my past life,
as Rina.
She
randomly,
the day of one of my
birthday event,
she randomly couldn't walk,
so I had to cancel it.
And I was wondering,
she was plopping her feet
and she couldn't pick up her back legs.
So we literally did
so many X-rays and scans
and ultrasounds.
I don't know if she had a surgery
or if she had a neurological issue.
No, she's totally fine.
They literally couldn't find anything wrong with her.
They have no idea. They did blood work.
All her blood work came back normal.
But she couldn't walk.
She couldn't move her back legs.
And then eventually it became her front legs.
And then she couldn't move her body or her tail.
So she was literally just paralyzed.
And I had to bring her to the bathroom.
There's like a clip someone took of me.
And I'm like, sorry,
so she can shit because she couldn't posture.
And I would carry...
Fiya's very good at communicating.
So she has a little bed that I would put her in
and I would just carry her around the bed
and I'd bring over her litter box.
She meow, no.
Or I'd bring her over to the food and she wouldn't meow.
So that means I just set her down so she wants to eat.
So she was very good at telling me what she wanted.
I gave her medication every day.
She was on three different medications.
And finally,
when she got her on an antibiotic,
she saw a plethora of doctors,
thousands of dollars in vet bills
that I'm still trying to pay off.
Yes, for a month,
almost three months,
I was literally waiting on her hand and foot.
I was another reason why I went on a mental leave
because I couldn't take the toll
because she hadn't even turned a year yet
and I thought I was going to have to put my cat down.
So it was really tough.
And I love her to death.
I just want her to fucking live to her first year.
That's all I want.
And then when I was
accepted to be a lawyer, I literally was like,
oh my god, thank you fucking,
thank you universe for this.
And then,
Stroni was just like, I'll pay for stuff.
I'll do this, I'll do that.
I was like, nah, but she did help me
with a bill.
So I've already paid her back.
But I was just very appreciative
of that.
And it's happening again.
She can't move her back legs.
So her body is slowly just
not being able to
support her.
So she can't walk.
She'll try, she'll like kind of drag herself
towards me
because she wants to be picked up.
That's why I get the big stretch
because I would have to do physical therapy
because her muscles started to atrophy
because she didn't move for like a month and a half.
And she was so small
and so tiny.
I generally didn't think that she was going to make it.
But she did.
She got around these antibiotics
because one doctor was like, oh, maybe she
has this. I don't fucking know.
And so we just threw shit at the wall
and hope that it sticks.
And it did. So I am hoping
that
the antibiotics help her again.
I don't know if she has some sort of viral thing
that just like makes her shut down
her ability to,
I don't know any virus like that.
The doctor said it could be toxoplasmosis
which is why they have
women who are pregnant
not scoop litter boxes because
humans can get it and like it's very
dangerous.
So I think
they like they have no idea but they're like
maybe she has that but they tested her
for it and it didn't really come back for anything.
But hey, it worked so
we don't really care.
So I already started her in the meds.
The doctor and like
I emailed her like in like 5am
because I woke up because I just have
like a fucking sixth sense about those
things. And I noticed
that Fia like was just
stuck under the bed and that's where she is
now but she's on the edge
so I can pull her out if I can like bring her
to the litter box or bring her to the
thing.
But yeah, I'm very
and that's why I have that crate is
because I would have to crater when I left
when I had to go to work or anything
but I essentially
was literally just being her caretaker
around the clock.
How long does it take for the meds to kick in? I have no idea.
No clue.
But I'm hoping it's soon.
All I know is that
she can be fixed, that she can be
okay, that it is something
that must flare up every once in a while.
I'm thinking it might have happened
because she was stressed that I was gone
is my guess.
Or I don't know if
like
my mom's like maybe like boomie
like passes something along
to her and like all the other cats are immune
but Fia and I'm like maybe she just
like I'm pretty sure like Fia is just like immune
no deficient.
The foster mom
because I rescued Fia from the south
from like Mississippi so that's
why I get that Mississippi joke a lot.
I'm getting dizzy a little bit.
She said her sister
passed away from complications
because she couldn't move and so I'm wondering
if it's like a congenital thing
or she was born with this condition.
But yeah.
But I gave
her all the vet
minus the vet pills because
again you guys know how much I fucking
know in vet pills. It's a lot.
The vet like was literally
what I like with the vet is she tried to
cut corners for prices
where she could. She like reduced a lot of pricing
for me because she knew it was like really
like again like thousands and thousands
of dollars just to try to save my cat
and
yeah I'm wondering
if like the stress of me being gone
triggered it
or something else or like
my mom was cleaning the litter box while I was gone
so like the litter boxes weren't dirty
so there couldn't be like a bacterial infection.
They literally don't know
it's not they don't think it's by food
she doesn't seem allergic to anything.
So many tests so much stuff.
I'm sorry to dump that all on you
but I just want to give you context
as to kind of what I'm dealing with
and I have been dealing with since March
I'm just I am just
thankful that
it can be sorted and that she can
be fine and she can play and she can run
and she can jump
eventually and so I'm just gonna
wait for that to happen
I'm gonna hope that the antibiotics work
and if not there are two other medications
she was on that will probably all bring them all
into rotation again
I'm just gonna tackle it. I will fight for Fia
she is my baby
she is my she
was with Reina when Reina was sick. I still have to bring Reina
to the vet because they're like oh yeah Reina might have cancer
and I'm like fucking
great like come on
stop and then I'm motion sick and I can't even
bring my cat to the vet
I still think
when my mom drove me today to get her meds
um
yeah it's just really
shitty because my cats are my life they're all I have
besides you guys and my family
it just sucks
Reina I'm kind of
may peace with because she's 14
she already has a lot of health issues
she's got kidney disease she's in my arms
right now purring
um
why did you get sick all of a sudden and I think it was from traveling
my mom was
wondering if I got oh I have to tell you guys
what happened I didn't tell you guys what happened
to me I'm so sorry that I'm kind of just dumping
this on you but
uh I haven't seen my therapist yet
so I'm just gonna tell you guys instead
um
yeah Reina's
being a cutie on my lap I have to bring Reina
to the vet to get her calcium check
she either has a thyroid issue or she is cancer
you better not have fucking cancer
or I'll be pissed
if she has cancer
I don't think she would be able to survive treatment
so I don't want to put her through that
we'll see
um she's she was playing and running around
today so I honestly
she was eating a lot
so I'm wondering if um this is like a
thyroid issue because that just makes
way more sense to me because it's
just makes more sense with what else
she's going on um
I know literally
the house and everything goes wrong uh
and
my mom said she noticed it
that Fia was acting weird
when my mom first came to visit she was checking
on her she says she was very
my cats are very friendly
she's like Fia was hiding under the bed she didn't want
to come out and she usually she only does
that if she feels like she's
not feeling good or she feels threatened
like a cat doesn't want to be bothered
and all that stuff so I'm like hmm interesting
um but as for me
uh yeah I
traveling was a nightmare I died I
I'm gonna have to do it again soon um
and I don't want to do
it I have to travel again like October
I still don't know the dates for another
thing another family thing
I think that'll also
be it won't be in Florida again but
I just got really dizzy
because I'm moving my head around
looking for the cats um
so yeah
I'll give you the rundown
so what was supposed to
so I I didn't tell you guys
because I also didn't say a lot what was going on
with me or talk about
what was going on with me because I didn't want you guys to worry
and I didn't just want to go on my twitter and
just like be like my life sucks
this happened that happened this
happened um but I did have a layover
um
an ATL if you guys just like be in
an airport um
and to get to
the place where I was going
and what should have been
like a quick flight
afterwards
turned out to be
like four hours of waiting
on a taxiway because I think
around that time is when the stuff went down
but we didn't know that
um yeah I hate that fucking airport
I'll tell you that right now
um I hate airports
I hate crowds of people I like
I get sick very easily
and I'm surprised I didn't get sick
I immediately took a shower
when I got to my family's house
and I was like I need to get this gross off me
so I already had
a few hours and then I had to wait
another few hours
and I just hate I didn't have a direct flight
so I'm just like I hate it here
um
and then I didn't get to my
grandparents house until like
3am because they couldn't come pick me up
because they're older and they don't have the luxury
of driving at night like I didn't want to put them
in that situation so I took me a while to
excuse me find me a
ride I couldn't get a rental car
there's no rental cars available
um
and
I managed to get an Uber and I
dropped a good chunk of change on an Uber
so that was fun
then I finally got there and I was half dead
and then
the weather was shit the majority of the time
so I couldn't really do a lot
there was like one sunny day
and it was just gross and humid and I hated it
I think honestly the only funny thing
was when that frog somehow got in the house
into the toilet
it was fun catching it
because my whole family was like
and I'm the only one that likes
bugs and like amphibians
and reptiles and invertebrates
so I just like yanked it and I'm like
you're mine you're gonna be my friend
I was gonna kiss it
and then my but my grandmother was
freaking out so I didn't do that
but our frog and a snake
I've grabbed snakes before
um when I would go with my
I've mentioned my grandfather before when I would go
in the woods my grandfather I snatched a snake up
and like I know I know my snakes
so I know one one's poisonous
and one's not
it was like a little rat snake that I
snatched and I was like
frog was cannon
and so yeah I put the frog outside
somebody was like flush it I'm like
what that's just messed up
and I'm not gonna flush a frog down the toilet
although I know that's where you crawled up from
but it was it was really weird
I felt something wet on my butt cheek
um it was because
the frog was behind the seat
and it was like trying to get away from my fat ass
I was just gonna sit on it
um
so I left it outside
that was me my pet
I was about to drop some heat too I was like
I was about to blow that shit up
that's probably what it died
cause I get really sick after it cause I get
motion sick and the motion sick makes me nauseous
and the nauseous gives me tummy upset
and that was just a bad thing
um and then so I finally
like we're hanging out whatever
is fine but I was so
tired and I felt so
crappy the entire time
that we couldn't really do anything so I literally
just like watched Elden Ring videos
and I forgot my switch
and I was pissed cause
like my family likes to play like Mario Party
when we're all together like that was our thing
like they always come over our house
my family's house and we all play Mario Party
um a frog was spared
um
nobody got there a snake
no a knife
no um
I
like Elden Ring
I'm so happy it's my hyper fixation again
cause I need that I need a distraction
and Elden Ring is my distraction
um
cause I also didn't want to hear talk about church
and stuff for my family
um and then
going back was also a nightmare
uh go ahead and do an overlay
an overlay
a layover in ATL again
and there's so many people trapped in that airport
um because the flights
were all messed up
for like a lot of the airlines
and it sucked
I heard so many stories
people in the south
they're just so nice those telling you anything
to a woman she's telling me her whole life story
and I'm just like
I'm from the north I'm like who the fuck do you think you talk
don't talk to me then I'm like but then you know
I put on my sweet smile
and I'm like hey okay
um
new theory about
America being a jar person
instead of being a normal being
nice
amazing theory I think you should
she definitely do a deep dive
did your family question you about your job they did
it was very awkward
I just kept saying I was under NDA
and then I was just like
I'm just a voice actor
actress whatever um and I worked for
a social media startup so I was just like throwing out everything
I should have said I worked for the government
but I don't think my grandparents would believe me
um yeah we don't do that up there
we don't do that up in the north
mm-mm
we're hard and cold in the north
um
all the ones words literally
and uh
and then so stuck there
my I was up till
since 3 a.m. because you guys
like in my space I was like
I'm doing my makeup now I'm getting ready
now because I'm not going to be able to do this
when I first wake up I'm happy I did that
um I woke up at 3
I got made sure everything was good
I called an Uber for about
because they couldn't drive me
like an hour and a half
and then finally around
like 4.30
I was able to snag one
and this dude
decides to just talk to me the entire time
and I'm like dude it's 4 a.m.
why are you fucking talking to me
just drive me to the damn airport
um
I just got shadow limbs
and the broken bits
shadows like a jar or houses ill
are you being legit with your theory
because I'm going to laugh at you
anyways
uh but like
I'm like I can be nice so I was like
I'll humor people
um
my first my first Uber driver
that like drove me to my grandparents house
was like very south he's like yeah I fought in the war
you know that plane you just came off on
you know
I've been one of those and I almost fell out
of one of those and my sergeant I was like
bro are you telling me a story about how you almost
died in one of the planes I was in
why are you doing this to me
like I hate this
um
and so then I get to the airport
I like
what is it
my flight leaves at
6.50
should always get to the airport like 2 to 3 hours early
um
did that
flew
like
an hour late
it was delayed an hour
jealousy stop
um
why do you spell her name wrong
every time you type it
Merica Merica Merica
Merica
oh my god
um and then I get
to ATL
and I think we got delayed like 3 hours
um
and then the flight took to I was so over it
I was so fucking over it
and it's not I'm not done yet
I'm not done yet I finally land
where I'm supposed to be
America
Merica
um
and my mom's unable to pick me up
from the airport so I'm like okay I'll take
public transportation
and so I'm
going different places
going to different taking a bus
doing the train doing this bus
doing this taxi and I'm trying to get
closer so my mom can pick me up
to a closer town
um
and then my dad's like
oh
you're near me
why didn't you just say so
come back this way the place that you finally
oh because I got to the
I got to a train station
and the trains like oh you're you just missed a train
it's about an hour and I'm literally like I'm going
to throw myself in the tracks right now
it was
I got up at 3am it was
the train won't come till 3.45 I'm like I'm ending
my life in Minecraft
right on these tracks and you can do nothing about it
conductor
um
and so
my dad's like oh why didn't you just say
that you were nearby
because then you can just come over here
and pretty much retrace
the last two hours that you took
and come back to my work
and I'll drive you home and I'm like
dad are you
I told you the plan with mom
I was going to take
this train
to go to this town
mom would pick me up at this station
and I told you that like
literally like
when I got off the plane and you're saying oh wait
that's right
I forget you're near me
I'll drive you home and I'm like
dad
dad why
mmm
so I did I went back
I went all the way back took a train
took a bus took a taxi you went back to
where I came from
and then
I take a train
to near where my dad works
and
I have to
walk
with my suitcase and it's like super fucking
hot out and I have to walk
to go down this plethora of stairs
and I have to walk
and walk and walk
and my dad's like where are you
and I'm like what do you mean he's like
you're not by
these stairs like in certain name
here redacted stairs I'm like
fuck I went the wrong way
so I had to walk back
walk to retrace all my decks and walk
back and go down the other opposite
way
and then I got to go down the stairs
I got to go down this path
I got to go this place
ladies dog is barking at me
I'm like
fuck you dog
I love dogs but you're just pissing me off
today my dad's like do you want me to pick
you up I'm like I'm here I'm
literally in the parking lot don't you
dare fucking leave
I will lose my mind
and my dad's like okay my car's
unlocked you can throw your stuff so I do that do that
and my dad's like
so I have to work still
I'm like
dad please just take me home
dad please
I'm stealing your car and I'm driving
myself
no I probably couldn't drive in the condition I wasn't
um
yeah I fucking I didn't feel like a vacation
I didn't
it
it was honestly like I usually have so much
fun I usually like and it was the worst
travel experience of my fucking life
and I hated it so much
oh and so
my dad
drives me home
after showing off his cool little mini
laptop gamepad thing he's like I can get
steam on it you're showing me all this old
steam games it's like half life
portal
counter strike source
he's like I'm buying risk I'm like you're an old man
um
yeah it was a lot it was
so bad it was so bad guys
um
it was hot the entire time
I hope they're better and it's funny
then I get home I'm chilling
I'm like oh I
take a shower I'm having a great
time
I'm like wow I feel great
actually no before
that I get
in the elevator in my apartment I go
up to my floor I step
off and sometimes every time I usually
step off an elevator I'll get a little vertigo
hello
was he showing off Mario Kart no he wasn't
he got like this freaking
thousand dollar my mom is so pissed at him
he got this like
thousand dollar mini gaming laptop thing
and I'm like what the fuck is this he's like it was
prime day and I'm like okay whatever
you're a grown ass man I can't tell you what to spend
yeah all the stress is caught that's what my mom said she's like
you were stressed out when you realize
you were home your body just crumbled
I step out
and I'm like I'm feeling a little bit wavy like I just
stepped off of a boat I'm like whatever it'll
go away because it's happened to me before
I usually
always get motion sick on escalators
elevators like moving
pathways
the littlest thing
social security
social security what the fuck is that supposed to mean
my dad has a whole ass
job what do you mean
the fuck who the hell
um
and uh
so
and then I take a shower and I'm realizing I'm dizzy
and I'm like whatever I'm gonna sleep it off
I probably just have a headache from the heat
I didn't drink enough water that's a fact
um
and
I wake up and I have the
worst fucking motion sickness
and I'm not done yet
I'm not done my story
so as you guys know I was been motion sick
I'm still motion sick
um
uh yeah the last time I also had vertigo
this bad it was
I had
covid and then literally
the day before I didn't know I had covid I went to an
amusement park when I had covid whoops
and
unlike one of those like spinny
I don't know what the fuck it's called it was six flags
I don't know
which six flags right it was
but it just spun you around a lot
and I was so
I should have never done that
it wasn't teacups
but it was something yeah it was like a world
gig looking thing that's a good way to say it
um
and
I hadn't felt like that a while
and so
I just literally had had all the
I don't have curtains
but I have all the blinds closed
I've had the lights off
I'm just listening to Elden Ring Lore
I'd sometimes try to read
the book that I bought at the airport
uh Raina and Fia were with me
Boomi snuggled with me for a little bit
which I was surprised because he
he loves attention but he doesn't smuggle with you
um but he the cats were
so happy to see me Boomi was screaming
when I got home he Boomi doesn't meow
you guys hear him he goes
and that's all he does he was yelling in surprise
um yes getting curtains
soon thank god
um
yeah it's like my mom that you guys got me
like the curtains the rod
this and that she was like
her mouth was just open the entire time
she's like what
they got you all that and I'm like yeah
cause they're fucking amazing mom
and I don't know what I knew about them
um
thank you morrigan
I need that so bad
I need you all just to come into my bed
and just hold me
thank you so much
for the tip morrigan
yeah it was it was like
and it sucks because I'm like
and that's where like I'm like I realize how fucking lonely
I am cause there's nobody here with me
besides my cats and I just
I just want to be taking care of
so bad you can hear my throat hurts
um
cause I'm getting choked up
uh
I'm a very lonely
sad woman
that's why I'm very parasocial
and um
so I'm motion sick the first
day it's terrible
I try to make myself some food
I try to move I try
it's bad I almost fell over
I did fall at one point but I was already
I just rolled off the couch it wasn't a big deal
and I'm like oh my god
and so I took like
um some medication for it
I have like the non drowsy
um Dramamine
or whatever it is it's like male cuisine
took that didn't do shit
took my other meds
I'm like fuck
that didn't really help I don't know why I thought it would
um
and then
it's the next day
in the middle of the day
I get the worst pains
of my life
uh
and I don't even know what triggered it
I don't know if I got food poisoning
I don't know if I have a had a virus
or have a virus currently that I'm just like
working out of my system
I thought fun story time
was enemies were prayer friends
I was one random tough man so it was really
um
I
felt like I was
being
stabbed
in the gut
and the pain was so
unbearable I was trying not to
cry I have a very high pain
tolerance but it was bad
um
it was probably some of the worst excruciating
pain I've ever felt
and
it was it was just horrible
I would never want to go through that again
um it was horrible
because it was affecting because like how
uh
I think it never bothered me the first time like
because I've had pain like that
but I didn't have fibro when I had pain like that
so it's different now because it hurts all the
nerves in my body so my like
that from I started from my stomach
it shot down my legs I don't know if you guys
have ever had sciatica
or sciatic pain
I had both my legs uh it also shot
through my chest and into my shoulder and
down my right arm
and that's my arm that's bad and my
shoulders messed up um
I was really just curled up on a ball
I really ripped up all my clothes
I was just naked laying
on the cold floor and just rocking myself
and I thought I was gonna die
and I didn't know what was gonna happen
and
it sounds like a I thought I
literally thought it was like as I
didn't know if I was having a heart attack I didn't know
if my I thought my appendix was
exploding
um I was so scared
because I'm like
family's just gonna come in
because my mom has a key to my place
and she's just gonna find me dead naked
in my bathroom and just like
not know what the fuck happened to me
and I'm literally sitting there
and I feel my body just
going cold and I'm like
oh this is it this is how I die
I wasn't so pain
and I was just like my phone was across the room
I couldn't call 911
um I couldn't call my parents
my watch was far away from me
because I had taken it off to shower
uh not yeah
and I just never put it back on the charger
or pack anywhere and so I was really just like
and then I managed to pull myself onto the toilet
um
and uh
I have a tummy upset
and then at the same time
from both ends
uh
I started just puking
in my sink just
fucking projectile vomiting
sweating
cold thinking I'm dying
I'm like great my body
shutting down I'm expelling all the
waste
um
it was bad
it was so bad but then I felt
better after I puked and I was just like
fuck do I have food poisoning and I'm like
I didn't even eat anything bad
that's what yeah when you when you guys saw that tweet
saying I threw up
that was literally what had just happened
uh I did feel better
and I decided like you know
it was I had to put like
it was bad
like it was bad in my sink and so I like
I had like
almost drunkenly clean up everything
and like
there's some drano down and hope that I caught
rid of it
and my cats are all around me
and they know something's wrong
like rena was
uh and boomie were like by my side
fia was like off
to the side but like
um rena was always on top of me for that
shit she's like she was up in my face
she was checking she was sniffing me she knew
something was wrong um
cats were like damn girl you could
uh
um
and then
I texted my mom right after because I'm like
mom I don't feel good I don't know what's wrong
with me uh please just check in with me
every now and then because I don't know what's wrong
with me and she's like do we need to take you to urgent care
and I'm like wait I don't have insurance
so don't take me to urgent care
because ambulances are expensive
y'all
like 20k in the US
um
yeah it's
it's
that's why like I didn't tweet a lot
about what I was fucking dealing with
because I didn't want you guys to worry
um
but yeah it was hard it was tough
it was bad
we suffered in America literally
my friend had a baby she still was like
30k
like damn bitch
um
but then
I got up
cleaned up
uh
and just laid on the floor on the cold
tile
because I was just
like I was cold and then I was hot
so I don't know if I had food poisoning or something
I don't know
um
I literally had just like
eaten some rice
and then I had like sweet potatoes
I don't
know
it was so weird
uh
and um
and I had some like dressing on it
but the dressing isn't
wasn't bad I literally like had ordered
food so I'm like
was the food bad from this place that I ordered from
again I just
I don't know
some rice left out too long to grow some stuff
yeah that's no
no wherever she goes
she's down with the sickness
oh wow
but guys
don't think this doesn't happen on like a daily occurrence
hello
hello welcome in
I has medical expenses
of thing when someone needs medical attention
I don't fucking know I hate America for that reason
she went to fly to another country to get healthcare
and fly back literally
is she a doctor?
I don't know
I'm not going to say that
but here's what I'll tell you
because this is exactly what happened last time
my throat hurts
last time this happened to me
I went to urgent care
uh
they gave me the same pills that I have
just the milk cuisine or whatever it's called
literally just gave me like over-the-counter
or uh prescription
it didn't do shit
I literally just had to wait it out
I don't like 300 bucks
for a waste of my time
and a waste of gas to tell them to tell me
oh here's some drugs
no
I hate that
I hate going to the doctor because they literally don't do shit besides
like you want some drugs and I'm like
I have been on so many medications
between my like
for my mental health, for my physical health
for my um
neuropathy
for like rheumatology issues
I'm like I'm tired of taking fucking
pills bro
I'm trying like
I would go totally holistic
if I could because I'm so
fucking tired of taking pills dude
um I literally don't
yeah that's why like that's the only
like what I was like alright
I think I have a stabbing pain in my gut
I'm puking my guts out
my body's gone cold
my organs must be shutting down
I will then
possibly
think about getting a
going to the
the doctors
I can see one of those medical recast videos
getting made, VTuber eats moldy rice
this is what happened to her body
I had like moldy bread on accident the other day and I was fine
I had salmon that was
left out in water
defrosting that I forgot
about I was fine I'm like
what the fuck is going on I think
that's why I'm like my mom just said I think
your body was just so stress
and you had already had something inside
that you just your when you finally
got to relax your body just like couldn't
take it
yeah they add up
only bread
has pedestal that's fine
it's some weird thing when I was a state
very similar to when I've been high for two
days straight I went to the ER
waited for three hours for them to tell me it's nothing
that's so crazy yeah it was so I had
the spins and I'm like
I didn't drink anything I don't drink
because of my medication I only drink for special occasions
so like I might I usually
won't take my
prescription for like a day
so I don't think it'll interact with it
and I literally had the spins
I thought I was on a boat
and I'm like
I feel high
and I'm like if this is what being high is like
I never want to be high bro
this fucking sucks
um the room is spinning my throat is dry
right now uh sorry
I'm not used to talking so much again
I have to get used to yapping
um
yeah so
my body was like not can't do it
I'm done
and then like the shit going on in the world
I'm like bro I'm so over it
I'm so I just want to I wish
being a v2 I wish I was like
inside my computer in my little sex
dungeon I mean my
hotel
just live in life my anime
dreams
um
a v worm
thing I don't know what that is what's a v worm
thing
I mean hey I was
so stressed when I was younger I was down
multiple days so tracks yeah it was definitely
like I think I was so stressed out and then I'm
still stressed out because
rain is not feeling good I'm not feeling good
fee is not feeling good and so it's just
I'm very stressed and I'm sorry
because I I feel really bad
because there's so many fucking projects
I want to get done and there's stuff that I
want to get done for you guys and I fucking
can't do it because I'm sick
and it pisses me off
it literally pisses me off because I'm like I want
to stream I want to do this I want to do that I want to
do this I want to have this collab I want to do this
I want to hang out
and it pisses me the fuck off
ugh
yeah I feel that that's what rain has been doing
oh
aw baby
aw one of the family dogs
that I grew up with
kind of was in the same boat
so I get that I'm so sorry
that you're going through that because I told
the um emphasize
empathize with that you sympathize
you know what I mean
I can't talk right now
um
because I hate being that like
sick girl corpo meme
and I hate being like wow shabby is really falling apart
I'm not I'm tougher than you fucking
think I just don't tell you
because I don't want you to worry I'm only telling you now
because I know transparency is important
um
but like don't worry I can take care
of myself I'm okay
uh this is
literally just a one-time thing because I traveled
and I'm now I know what to look out for
when I travel again
and
I will get through it I'm tough
my mom's a fucking
tough person my dad's a tough person
you guys don't even know what they've been through health wise
and I'm like if I'm
a quarter if I'm a percentage
of anything like them I will be fine
um
but you don't have to baby me you don't have to
be like oh madam did you do this
did you do that don't
worry about that I'm
still a grown ass woman I can still take care
of myself I still
appreciate your support whether it be emotional
or financial thank you
um
tough people need care too though
you're right I'm so used to taking care
of other people I don't I sometimes ever get to take care
of myself my mom has told me that before
um and that's why she was
happy that I left my last job because
I was so busy cleaning up other people's messes
and just like doing stuff for other people
she's like you need to do something for you
that gives you energy stop giving
your energy to other people
um
you know stressful things that yeah you guys understand
with my OCD I need to be in control
and nothing's in control right now and it's
not going my way and it's very stressful
um
it's very stressful what
if we want to baby you
I'll have to be cute and funny for you to
baby me well I'm like this
I'm not gonna baby me that's just
that's just silly
um
I don't know that doubts the resilience
that's my word of the year is resilience I
aiming I'm aiming to be resilient
so one of the first things I've noticed about
you plus you know how to don't take anyone's crap
sometimes I do
sometimes uh
yeah like I tweeted something stupid the other day
and the day after I tweeted it I'm like why the fuck did I tweet that
like why am I being a little bitch right now
am I getting one guide and I like
deleted it I was gonna delete it sooner
but I'm like I just like got distracted
resilient bouncing no
I'm still taller than you
you don't have me on my knee
um
but yeah it's just like
it's just
I'm still dizzy like I'm
I'm a little nauseous right now
I'm not nauseous actually I'm just motion sick
I can't move my head a lot and I'm moving
I'm gesturing so I need to stop
um
I hope you guys like the tan toggle
I might
I realize I'm darker like
on
whoa
yo
I kind of like the upturned hair
hello the physics
um it's I realize I'm lighter
on one display versus the other
in my displays they're literally the same freaking
model but they have differently
I tried I matched up all like
the gamma saturation all the shit
but one's darker than the other it makes no fucking
sense to me
um
but I'm happy you guys
it's on the other but it's because I'm flipped
that's why I flipped myself
I might flip myself back
tada
um
yeah so now people are like
she be abandoned her race
she's no longer
chock shut your horn mouth
I've always been shocked don't you forget
it don't you
fucking forget it
I don't know I went blue-eyed it's like
that that that uh what's it called
what's it called
just that that
mulatto stare just like when they got blue
eyes
you really want they really want you to know
your blue eyes
um
yeah
scrawny's also cooking
and some other stuff
I also need to cook
enough alternative outfits possibly
because they already because if I do
an alternate outfit for like a
donothon gold and they already want to
start conceptualizing it so
yeah like kocho
now you can switch
defending on what you want to say
I can't give myself the pass
um
yeah
alright we see him damn
do ya
you see him
as we're like wait her eyes changing color during stream
I was doing it sneakily
just to be silly
um
but I'm glad to be back
um thank you for letting me vent
I'm sorry
uh I really
I literally like had so many things
planned for when I came back
like add some naughty stuff
they had some normal stuff
and I haven't been able to do that because it's
very hard for me to do stuff
like I'm already very dizzy right now
I think my brain just
caught up to all the game
that I was playing
ass go give it to ya what
um vent I'm ok
uh
but
yeah that's why I gave you guys
cute outfit
um I'll be honest with you that's an old picture though
I don't have any
I don't really take pictures of myself because what's the point
I'm a vtuber
um
but I know you guys would like you guys missed
out the Among Us one was way better
I was balancing I said this
I was balancing a crew
made on my bum in this like pretty
right underwear so
sucks for you guys
I was wearing a hat this is sus
but hey you guys
picked this leash because you want to see me
leash so
vote for dainty that was a cute little red dress
cute little red dress
hi
did you just hear Reina meow
she's meow back
she said hello back to me
I'll give you a hug Reina
oh thank you for the hug Reina
dainty bros
yeah I wasn't wearing a bra
on that one either so you can kind of see my piercings
Reina hi
she's purring love
Reina knows when I'm stressed out so she just wants to cling to me
how loud she's purring
I'm failed by my people
what else
the Among Us
the dainty
leash
I regret the other one was oh the cat
that was me and those little cat paw tights
a cute little pink dress
and tail and cat ears
I don't know I like stepped
in makeup on those tights
like literally right after I took the photos
I remember and I had to it toss them
I want to get some more cat paw tights
those are cute
my little paw pads
can we have like I just thought of like walking on my toes
because like walking in the tights
and like walking the cats walk on their toes
is it an
is it an autistic thing
to walk on your toes so you don't
make noise
because I didn't know that
I don't understand how that's a thing
Reina what are you doing you got something in your ear
or so
because like why is that a thing
I don't think so yes I think so
is it I do that
but I'm not autistic I think
I think it's somewhat common yeah
because I don't like making noise when I walk
okay
at least I'm not the only person
that doesn't that does that
the walks on our toes sometimes
like I'll just do it in general
I just don't like making noise when I walk at all
so I'll walk weird
my mom says I bounce when I walk
she's like why are you so bouncy
just walk normal and I'm like I don't know
Reina just had to put the mic
I need to get a little
cat
mascot
in the form of Reina
because I don't know if I get all three cats
and just like have them surround me
she tip toes like a cartoon
villain yeah exactly
but yeah I'm very glad
to
Reina on your head
yeah I have one cat under each arm
and then Reina is just on my head
I don't know if I can make this model
and go bald I'll be honest with you
I'll have to do try to figure out a bald toggle
they add the cats
to the family treat no they're not
they're just my babies they're separate
they're not part of that mess
I know people who did that a lot
don't get surgery later in life
because doing that messed up their legs
oh walking in your toes
oh maybe
it's called it it's on a family treat
it's a wreath alright so I'm gonna say
um
I don't know what I'm gonna say
I'm just like
losing my train of thought
no wreath
w-r-e-a-t-h
wreath
using a sentence
my mom made a beautiful Christmas wreath this year
wreath
I was good in spelling bees
so I'm gonna say
wreath
they also uh
when they updated my model for the toggle
they also changed my mouth tracking
so it's a little bit weirder and I have to fix it again
my mouth doesn't open all the way
it's very odd
can I get a location of origin
I don't fucking know well no
I can't give you an a- they need
the person who's
testing you gives a location
of origin
velar spelling bee
strani can't spell
because she's Scottish
Azura
I think would just fall asleep
and they would go to her turn
and she'd just be asleep
uh mercy
would do well
emmy
would only ask for
words that were inappropriate
I see would just
be like
this is not fair
English isn't my first language
after she gets like one word wrong
and we give her a second
and she would just be like
no
let me so we'd have to like give her like
Russian words
haha
yeah because
Scottish spelling is very phonetic
very much like krill
yeah all my fucking god
you expect me to spell this shit
and she just fucking like
eat something across the room right now
I just was gonna go put right on the ground
and she just immediately just
gripped my shoulder
um
but yeah
it's like a club
it's funny so
strani really shouldn't have
set this up like this
but she puts all of our models in a drive
folder
but
but I see and Emmys are separate
so I can't get to their models
I was like really debating whether or not
I'm gonna come back and I'm just like
mercy on the screen
because if I were I would totally
yank I see his model and be like
hello everybody
oh yeah
I'm hoping she's getting a well deserved break
she's been very stressed
make sure you guys if you're a snowberry
your dada give her lots of love
um
impressions yeah I can I can literally
only do icy though out of my gen mates
and then I can kind of do a zero
everyone swaps models
um
I would like show up
and like
because I like I could definitely grab like
mercy's or is there a model or strani's
I'm very tempted to yank
because strani has all our models too
I'm tempted to yank
because she backs them up for us
uh strani's model
when I collab with her
and just like show up as her and she'll be like
what the a**
what the f**k
I can't even do her voice right now
like
what the f**k in hell
yeah I just I'm sounding British
and then I'll just be like
eww reeflings look into my eyes
you're falling in love with me now instead
I'm the real
strani consoles
which girl would you want to do
a she be impression with your model
uh emmy or mercy
emmy is a good dom and mercy is a good
dom so I think
I think that would be really funny
uh
I would like to as you guys know
I love cute and funny stuff so I would
like to yank emmy's
or icy's model as a meme
although it'd be very funny
if me and zura were both like cute
and funny
and then
um I think or emmy would be funny
having strani's model
or icy was
strani's model
I see with the zura's model I'm just thinking of
all the combinations it's funny
mercy would just laugh
as she would she would just jiggle my boobs
I'm just gonna use the whip a lot
imposter oh no
I need to be strong
we are so back
you're right 3 fling we are so back
oh
mercy miss mental illness
if anybody's miss mental illness it's me
alright
um let me test it out your whip
anymore yet no I just got back
I just got here
I don't even know where it went oh yeah I shoved
it in my closet so my mom couldn't find it
but then I ended up kinda showing her
where it was because I put the cat
carrier in the same spot she's like
what if I need to get the cats out if there's
emergency and I'm like fuck
it's in the same spot as I put the whip
so I had to take out the whip
and then take out the cat carrier
and be like it's right here and then put it back
pretend that everything
was normal
how would you power
scale you and the girls
based off of what
Azura
is gonna be the most powerful she's literally
god
so
um and then
strongy
no no and then emmy because of her
book and then strongy because her hypnotism
I
I'm
literally probably the weakest now
they think of it I see because
of her polar bear upbringing
mercy because she just knows how to kill
people and torture them
and me I'm just
I just do that sexually so I'm like I'm
I yeah
I guess I'm the weakest
affection meter
um
she was just
I'm just some girl I'm just some bunny girl
that runs a hotel
bro
I'm just freaky canonical
I'm literally the only freaky one canonically
everybody else is normal
like if you really think about it I'm the actual
one that's like on the nose for my
my my uh my niche
um for affection
hmm that's a tough one
I would say
who's the most affectionate
for their fans
I would honestly say that
me and strongy are tied
at the top
then emmy
then I see
the mercy and azura
I think that's how I do it
I think
me and
strongy are very similar in our
affection
yeah it's hard to rank that because
we all like show our affection in different
ways
mercy was an ex student yeah but she
fucking kills people
um
because me and strongy
I think
are very
and yes I'll use this term
just because of how we are like we just
like spending time with you
um and we just talk a lot and we just want to
hang out and play games with you
um
emmy is as different because
again it's familial
and a little like
it's yeah it's
really hard
to
kind of because everybody kind of expresses
themselves in different ways
I don't know if she be you can just pull off
your own voice and make someone do whatever you want
that's true I liked so like in my
PL I love switching my voice up because
people would come in and I'd be like hi everybody
my name is uh Rana Noi
and today we're just playing
whatever the fuck I was playing at the time
and um
then
they'd be like oh how's it going I'd be like it's
going fine thank you
and they're just like
was that somebody else
I don't know what you're talking about sorry
sorry
Laurie
I can't even do my higher pitch voice right now because
it's already my throat is dry
I don't know if my air is dry in my house
Rana why are you just staring at my go XLR
like you're gonna do something
she's
squeaked because I poked her but
what
can you can you do like an actual
meow instead of a sessu
sometimes just like silent meow she's like
like you can't hear it
she'll just open her mouth and like let out a
squeak like the light side a silence
squeak Rana speak to the people
that's not speaking to the people
you're just rubbing against the mic she went
Rana
no yes actually meow and stop
whisper meowing
Rana say hi
she just keeps
whisper meowing
Rana
she just did it again she just whisper
meowing and whisper purring
that's what she does
she just opens her mouth and goes
if I put her in the ground maybe she'll meow
Rana
raise your voice
say hi
she just squeaked again
he heard that oh hello again
Rana just hopped on my desk and back on my lap
hi hi Rana
you gonna come give me a hug okay
doesn't Rana mean queen in Spanish
or is that a coincidence
it is it's spelled R E
Rana
queen in Spanish
but that's not how I spell her name
excuse me I'm so sorry
it's the lean game
I'm drinking the lean game ourselves
and I'm not even joking this shit is delicious
like
I usually don't like mix drinks
like shake your drinks but I'm like
this slaps
I ripped earlier
it's really good it's like I love peach
stuff and peach lemonade
no I'm not drinking lean like I'm not drinking
actual lean
bro
yeah I got a little robot susan
um no I'm drinking
the gamer subs flavor lean
it's peach lemonade flavor it's very good
it's caffeine free
I'm so happy I took the caffeine free one
because I probably wouldn't sleep
yeah I'm leaning to the side
because I have motion sickness
um
it's really tasty
um and then
I usually don't like tropical
flavors but I tasted
the
the shyly
flavor and it's so good
and then the other one I think it's like
strawberry lime or like sour
strawberry um
the
the gorilla one I don't know what it's called
um it's like gorilla fart
6000 or something silly
I was like I don't know if I'm gonna light
those ones this sounds weird
and I'm like oh this is actually pretty good
they're all so good I also got like
samples of because it was a PR box
I got samples of
uh titty milk
um
mango
something and then dragon fruit
so I can't wait to try those yeah guacamole
gamer fart
that one was pretty good
yeah use code
she be a chick out get to see if it
feels silver veil yeah
because that one's like sour strawberry I want to try the
silver veil flavor
or these flavors a bunch of gamers
and vtubers named them what did you
expect
what is it
I don't even know what the titty milk one tastes like
the fart my tummy's just upset
um
this one too
just in my chat screaming
my code every time he has the chance to
um yeah
I definitely need to fix the rigging around my mouth
because I'm not as
and I'm I'm I'm emoting
as much as I normally do
so I don't know why
unless I over exaggerate
so I definitely need to fix my physics
I have my uh cover up
for my boobies coming soon
I'm going to be
um
what's it called
my chest will be covered
and I'll look like a normal businesswoman
hahaha
they're not going away
it's just a toggle
my
my chocolatey boobs
oh I'm like
I'm shaking and I'm shaking
Reyna and Reyna just going
hahaha
Reyna I'm sorry
damn girl
you got stimkey breath
I need to brush your teeth again
she just looked at me like I offended her
um yeah
I definitely need to change the coloring
on the model
because I like it looks lighter on one screen
but it's darker on the other so I might lighten myself up a little bit
for a little bit
copy um yeah as a game or something
Reyna's stinky
Reyna got a stinky breath
she just looked up back at me like
what the fuck bitch why are you exposing me
I kiss your forehead
ugh
ugh no more chocolate milk
I don't want her going on the milkers
guys I can toggle it
on and off
I'll probably just use it for thumbnails
hahaha
you got chocolate milk from
Azur although Azur is giving
a cover up too hers looks fucking sexy though
I was like I think this
is just making her look more hot
to be honest with you
um
but yeah YouTube hasn't been kind to us
erm
I forgot what I was going to say
hers is really pretty
damn with these eyes got you weak
oh yeah
I got you weak
yeah
it's nice that I'll be able to go between
I didn't realize how pale I was
cause I'm like if I turn
this is my ear color normally
and if I turn off that
I'm like
I don't remember being this pale
I don't remember being
I'm like really white
I don't remember being this white
I swear I was a little darker than this
like wasn't I darker than this
I swear I was darker than this
white woman jumps
where is she we go who is this white woman
getting used to the tan toggle so much already
but like I swear
cause like
it's so weird I bet if I loaded
it in my old model it would look hold on
I'm testing this Reina I need to put you on the floor
no Reina you almost scratched my freaking neck
trying to turn around to get back on my shoulder
I'm testing it
ignore what my model looks like
just ignore that
see I swear
don't worry about
you being like that
I swear I'm like a little bit
like I'm not as bright
I swear I'm not as bright
and now my model is more
like you could tell by the
the mouth tracking is a little bit better
and more responsive
actually let me look at the settings for that right now
while I'm here
settings
my mouth form
I need to take a picture of this
somebody
type in the chat
0.4
0.01
and then 1.3
Jesus fucking Christ
you guys will do it
thank you
and then I'm going to switch back
to the other model
Reina can you please
stop trying to seduce me
and to giving you more pets
I